dams et messieurs du gouvernement mes
chers collègues hier soir après la
france le terrorisme islamiste a frappé
l'autriche
nos pensées vont aux victimes de cette
attaque
abject barbare guidés par un fanatisme
aveugle dans un pays européens amis au
nom de la représentation nationale
j'exprime également notre solidarité
notre profonde compassion au peuple
autrichien et je vous invite à observer
un moment de recueillement
je vous remercie
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement la parole est à madame
sabine rubin monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale en août dernier
qu'avez vous fait pendant les vacances
apprenantes d1 pour vous apprendre du
précédente en confinement
qu'avez vous fait alors pour doter
suffisamment de d'établissement en
produits essentiels masques et gel pour
réquisitionner des locaux et embaucher
des étudiants permettant par exemple
l'accompagnement dans des classes
dédoublées début octobre
qu'avez vous fait pour répondre à
l'imminence d'une seconde vague qui
nécessitait un protocole sanitaire plus
drastiques
le 15 octobre dernier qu'avez vous fait
quand je vous alertaient sur la
potentielle dangerosité des masques dean
sinon les remplacer par de nouveaux
masques afnor mais toujours sans
garantie de traçabilité
quand le principe de précaution
l'exigent la semaine dernière qu'avez
vous fait pour consacrer la liberté
d'expression dans nos établissements
s'ils ont proposé un texte caviardé de
jaurès à lire aux jeunes qu'avez vous
fait pour donner aux enseignants
attendent échanges lors de l'hommage à
samuel parti a pâti si ce n'est plus qu
les les horaires à la dernière minute ce
que vous avez fait monsieur le ministre
je peux le dire ici vous avez semé la
pagaille en improvisant au jour le jour
en multipliant directive erratique et
contradictoires en alimentant des
stériles polémique sur les plateaux télé
est ce que vous faites maintenant c'est
réprimer les jeunes qui commencent à se
mobiliser pour un protocole sanitaire
digne de ce nom
alors voilà ce qu'il faudrait faire
monsieur le ministre dès aujourd'hui
donné consigne d'accepter l'allègement
des classes et la réorganisation des
cours partout le réclame la communauté
éducative qui elle sait de quoi elle
parle
anticiper et budgétisé dès à présent et
pour le mois de janvier
l'adaptation de toutes les écoles à une
crise due qu'aux vide tu seras non
seulement dur mais durable je n'ai pas
de question à vous poser monsieur le
ministre
sinon vous apportez à nouveau quelques
réponses je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est un
monsieur jean michel blanquer ministre
de l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
et des sports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés l'avaient débutée
sabine rubin dans votre nom question je
vais essayer de retenir ce qui permet
positivement de parler de cette rentrée
je crois déceler une déception dans dans
vos propos parce que chaque rentrée vous
voulez du désordre et une fois de plus
vous constatez qu on a réussi à rentrer
dans l'ordre
oui c'est avec dignité hier que toute la
france a rendu hommage à samuel paty et
n'enlevait rien à cette dignité s'il
vous plaît dans toute la france en effet
ça a été respectée et respecté comme
jamais je tiens à le dire et je donnerai
les éléments pour cela oui il y avait
les références pédagogique il y a eu la
vidéo de robert badinter qui a été vu
des centaines de milliers de fois par
nos élèves
la vidéo de l'équipe de france de
football vu plus d'un million de fois
l'ensemble du pays qui s'est unie autour
de sa mémoire
il n'y a aucune raison aujourd'hui de
vouloir relativiser cela et c'est bien
dommage que vous interveniez de cette
façon deuxièmement vous m'invitez
finalement à vous dire comment a été
préparé les l'on était préparé les
choses c'est sûr que si vous étiez
ministre de l'éducation nationale les
élèves seraient encore sur leur canapé
aujourd'hui depuis le mois de mars
parce que au moins deux mais monsieur
mélenchon nous expliquer qu'il fallait
pas rentrer au mois de juin il nous
disait la même chose
vous nous avez dit qu'il ne fallait pas
rentrer en septembre à l'heure et
maintenant il aurait fallu aussi se
donner plusieurs jours avant de rentrer
alors évidemment la solution de la
paresse c'est la vôtre
la solution de la facilité c'est
toujours la vôtre nous sommes un des
pays du monde qui a réussi le plus à
faire retrouver les élèves à l'école et
c'est une très bonne chose
les enfants retournent à l'école c'est
notre premier but est bien entendu
tous les français le désir et ceux qui
le désirent en premier ce sont les
professeurs et par delà toutes les
fausses polémiques que vous essayez de
pointer par exemple la polémique sur les
masques elle est fausse
nous avons encore la vie de lindsay si
hier qui dit qu'ils ne sont pas toxiques
donc il y a ceux qui veulent de la
polémique vous ceux qui veulent le
bien-être des professeurs et des élèves
nous merci monsieur le ministre
madame rubin quelques secondes monsieur
les choses seraient préparées depuis
mois d'août si j'étais à votre place
merci la parole est à monsieur charles
de courson
s'il vous plaît ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre
l'article 37 de votre décret du 29
octobre 2020 a créé une forte rupture
d'égalité entre d'une part des
hypermarchés et des supermarchés qui
restaient ouverts tant pour leurs rayons
alimentaires que pour leurs rayons
non-alimentaires et d'autre part les
petits et moyens commerce non
alimentaire qui était fermé cette
rupture d'égalité a suscité de vives
protestations des petits et moyens
commerce non alimentaire qui au surplus
accueille un faible nombre de clients à
la fois alors que ce n'est pas le cas
pour les hypers et les supermarchés
de plus la fermeture des petits moyens
commerçants alimentaires a fait exploser
d'activité du e-commerce et ses
bénéfices amazon a triplé les siens
ainsi le gouvernement a fait voter un
impôt exceptionnel de un milliard et
demi sur les cotisations des
complémentaires santé au risque d'une
forte augmentation de ces dernières il
n'a pas songé à créer un impôt
exceptionnel sur les grandes entreprises
du e-commerce
devant les nombreuses protestations vous
avait alors modifié en catastrophe votre
décret du 29 octobre par un nouveau
décret du 2 novembre publié ce matin qui
interdit aux hypermarchés supermarchés
et magasins multi commerce de vendre des
produits non alimentaires sous réserve
de quelques exceptions alors monsieur le
premier ministre
j'ai trois questions à vous poser
première question comment allez-vous
faire respecter cette interdiction dans
les supermarchés hypermarchés alors que
dans certains de leurs rayons des
produits autorisés à la vente ou
interdits à la vente sont mélangés allez
vous créer des brigades de contrôle des
caddies pour vérifier que seuls des
produits essentiels sont vendus deuxième
question envisagez-vous d'autoriser les
petit et moyen commerce non alimentaire
de recevoir sur rendez-vous leur
clientèle comme mon groupe vous la
proposer dans notre courrier de vendredi
et troisième question envisagez vous de
créer un impôt exceptionnel sur les
grandes entreprises du e-commerce
mais si
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à monsieur bruno le maire
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la relance
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le député charles de courson je
vous croyais libéral je voulais couvre
ultra interventionniste plus
sérieusement nous avons avec le prêt
ministre jean castex rétabli l'équité
comme vous le souhaitiez
entre les petits commerces et les
grandes surfaces en exigeant qu'il n'y
ait pas deux poids deux mesures et que
chacun soit traité de la même manière
vous m'interrogez sur la taxation des
géants de lits commerce
je rappelle que nous sommes la première
nation en europe à avoir imposé les
errants du digital
enfin je veux vous dire monsieur de
courson parce que je sais que vous êtes
attachés comme tous les parlementaires
qui sont présents ici les commerces de
proximité sont des commerces essentiel
est essentielle à notre vie économique
est essentielle à notre vie culturelle
essentielle à notre vie sociale et nous
leur apporterons pendant toute la durée
du confinement tout le soutien dont ils
ont besoin le fonds de solidarité a été
porté à dix mille euros
les entreprises pourront faire du click
and collect et le chiffre d'affaires ne
sera pas déduits du fonds de solidarité
ils n'auront à payer aucune charge
sociale nous pourrons prendre en charge
leurs loyers grâce au crédit d'impôt que
vous avez voté nous allons leur
permettre de renouveler des prêts
garantis par l'état s'ils le souhaitent
les commerçants de france doivent savoir
qu'ils peuvent compter sur le soutien
complet total et entier de cette
majorité
enfin nous devons essayer de coursan
imaginez le commerce de demain et
l'imaginer ensemble nous voyons bien que
avoir une boutique sur 3 simplement qui
a un site internet qui numérise et ça
n'est pas suffisant
je ferai à la demande du premier
ministre castex dans la semaine des
propositions concrètes pour accélérer la
digitalisation de nos commerces qui
doivent savoir qu'elles peuvent compter
sur notre soutien total constant pendant
cette crise sanitaire
merci monsieur le ministre
cette course en 5 secondes michel
ministre vous n'avez répondu à aucune de
mes trois questions haute merci monsieur
le député la parole est à monsieur
cédric roussel
mr
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur mes chers collègues
nice est meurtri une nouvelle fois nice
pleure ses morts encore paroissiens la
basilique notre-dame de nice il avait le
goût des autres que leur nom résonne ici
longtemps
nadine de miller simone barrette au
silva vincent lokace ces morts
s'ajoutent aux victimes de l'horreur sur
la promenade des anglais à sa mère
pattie à tant d'autres
la france doit continuer de combattre
avec fermeté et sans répit des
islamistes qui nous ont déclaré la
guerre
monsieur le ministre les niçois les
français ne cherche pas un exutoire mais
la justice et leur sécurité
il ne s'agit pas mes chers collègues de
faire de la surenchère ultra-sécuritaire
nice vitrine de la vidéosurveillance n'a
pas été épargné nous ne gagnerons pas en
renonçant à l'état de droit et à nos
libertés
évidemment il ne s'agit pas non plus de
se coucher devant les ultimatums des
islamistes et d'oublier qui nous sommes
ce que nous sommes
alors oui la france doit être
intraitable ferme
elle sera forte être accra et combattre
à ses ennemis sans faillir la réponse
républicaine sera non aux propositions
et vos projets de loi elle sera dans
l'unité de la nation dans l'éducation et
l'émancipation dans l'information et le
renseignement dans la laïcité et le
droit la réponse doit également être
européenne
quand on voit viennent attaquer par des
sympathisants de dash cette nuit mais
aussi internationale après le massacre
de l'université de kaboul
car ne nous y trompons pas ce n'était
pas seulement la france ses églises ses
caricatures qui sont attaqué c'est nous
tous
qu'importe nos convictions nous tous et
la liberté alors monsieur le ministre
quelles sont les mesures de protection
que vous allez proposer dans le respect
des libertés aux niçois et plus
largement aux français je remercie
merci je suis député la parole est à
monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député et rossel je vous ai
évidemment m'associer aux homos de
reconnaissance envers d'abord les
victimes et leurs familles
bien sûr ces chrétiens assassinés dans
une église
tôt le matin à peine ouverte alors que
un office s'était même pas fait un
terroriste islamiste est venu semer la
mort et la terreur je voudrais avoir une
pensée pour nos forces de l'ordre
courageuse qui durant tout le week-end
des fêtes de la toussaint durant toute
cette rentrée scolaire avec tommy
l'éducation nationale on a eu l'occasion
de les remercier
on était aux avant-postes pour protéger
les français
dans des conditions nous savons monsieur
députés mesdames et messieurs les
députés j'ai eu l'occasion
maintes fois de dire christophe castaner
avant moi gérard collomb avant lui la
menace terroriste est forte
non seulement sur le territoire national
mais nous le voyons depuis encore hier
soir et vos propos monsieur le président
évidemment résonne particulièrement
aujourd'hui touche toute l'europe
occidentale
ce n'est pas qu'une affaire française
est d'ailleurs ce qui nous pousse à
fermer absolument toutes les frontières
un plus discuter dans un cadre européen
on voit bien qu'ils se trompent et ils
trompent les français avec des mesures
simplistes
alors que c'est l'europe et là certaines
idées que nous avons de l'europe et de
la liberté qui est attaqué par les
terroristes islamistes
enfin vous aurez monsieur le député a
voté je l'espère le texte de loi visant
à conforter des principes républicains
souhaitaient pas le premier ministre et
président de la république présente au
procès me ce 9 décembre prochain il
n'aura qu'un but lutter contre le
terrorisme
le terreau huîtres lequel l'islamisme
politique depuis de très nombreuses
années malheureusement prospère les
idéologues de malheur merci monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à monsieur eric ciotti
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre il s'appelait nadine
vincent simone ils sont tombés au coeur
de la basilique notre-dame de nice parce
qu'ils étaient chrétiens
nice a été touché pour la troisième fois
consécutive par le terrorisme ils ont
rejoint samuel paty et les 266 victimes
depuis 2012 de la barbarie islamiste
comme ils ont rejoint les victimes de
l'attentât de vienne je veux en cet
instant rendre hommage à leur mémoire et
penser à leurs familles
je veux aussi je veux aussi en cet
instant rendre hommage aux forces de
l'ordre et notamment les un peu oublier
aux policiers municipaux de nice primo
intervenants admirable de courage et qui
ont neutralisé le terroriste
monsieur le premier ministre vous nous
trouverez toujours à vos côtés pour
renforcer les armes dont nous avons
besoin pour gagner cette guerre contre
l'islamisme
mais pour cela des actes concrets et
immédiats sont fait indispensable alors
que les trois derniers attentats sont la
conséquence tous d'une immigration
incontrôlée
allez vous oui ou non mettre en place un
moratoire migratoires pour les pays qui
nous menacent alors que 2540 islamistes
sont sortis ou vont sortir de prison
entre 2018 et 2022
allez vous oui ou non mettre en place
des procédures de contrôle alors que
4100 étrangers sont fichés pour menaces
terroristes et que seulement 16 d'entre
eux ont été éloignés depuis septembre
allez vous oui ou non tous les expulsés
enfin alors que la menace est maximale
allez vous oui ou non activés l'état
d'urgence terroristes issus de la loi de
merci monsieur d'éviter la parole de
monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député ciotti je m'associe
évidemment comme je lé fais l'instant
pour votre collègue roussel pour les
mots que vous avez eu bien sûr pour les
victimes et leurs familles mais
également pour les policiers et
militaires
et bien sûr les policiers municipaux
partout en france et singulièrement à
nice qui ont neutralisé en premier ce
terroriste ils l'ont fait avec beaucoup
de courage le président de la république
qui s'est rendu sur place
puisque vous étiez du voyage vous l'avez
constaté a pu les remercier et les
féliciter
oui bien sûr nous sommes fermes
le député mais permettez moi quand même
un léger différend dans vos propos par
rapport à nos propos de commissions et
hier il ya vous m'avez interrogé en
donnant les mêmes chiffres monsieur
députés sur les étrangers en situation
irrégulière qui serait fiché au fsb rtcr
islamistes radicaux je peux comprendre
que vous n'ayez pas les informations des
mises de l'intérieur toute la commission
des lois a constaté que j'ai pris le
temps de détailler des chiffres que vous
avez donné qu'ils n'étaient pas les bons
chiffres
et voilà que vous répétez en séance
publique
des chiffres que vous savez faux
monsieur le député ciotti
ce n'est pas en mentant mais si vous
m'écoutez vous allez voir vous aurez des
réponses précises à des questions
précises qui sont très importantes
monsieur le député monsieur le député ne
mentez pas au moment où on parle de
terrorisme
je vois c'est extrêmement grave
les 4100 étrangers fichier fs prt je
voulais expliqué hier son 4100 étrangers
dans les fichiers de la dgsi et ils ne
sont pas tous ces étrangers sur le sol
national
c'est des étrangers que nous avons
d'ailleurs depuis longtemps parfois
expulsé et que nous interdisons de
retour sur le territoire national vous
auriez eu la gentillesse monsieur le
député peut-être d'évoquer que depuis
que le président de la république est
arrivé sur les 800 étrangers en
situation régulière qui l'a trouvé au
fsb rt plus de la moitié ont été
expulsés et les 200 qui reste le soro
c'est ça le dire la vérité aux français
merci monsieur mais nous la parole est à
valable christine pires bonne merci
temps au nom du groupe socialiste
souhaite m'en aussi apporter tout mon
soutien et ma solidarité au peuple
autrichien
monsieur le premier ministre aujourd'hui
la grande demande sur nos territoires
vous avez instauré une concurrence
déloyale entre grandes surfaces et
petits commerces de proximité condamnons
ces derniers au désespoir et malgré les
aides beaucoup ne s'en remettront pas et
vous le savez en quoi serait-il moins
dangereux d'aller acheter chabab sa
baguette chez le boulanger du centre
ville que d'acheter un livre dans la
librairie du coin ou un jouet en bois
pour noël dans la boutique d'à côté les
grandes surfaces de ma circonscription
où plusieurs centaines de personnes font
leurs tâches en même temps serait moins
dangereuse que les petits commerces de
riom ou de châtel les petits commerces
de pontaumur serait plus dangereux que
les nombreux self des lycées où des
centaines d'élèves se côtoient sans
masque et sans distanciation votre
gouvernement a choisi la mauvaise
solution fermer certains rayons de la
grande distribution
en somme vous proposez que tout le monde
y perdent sauf sa femme à zone qui se
frotte les mains de cette aubaine ds
l'inespéré
aujourd'hui c'est donc l'incompréhension
et la colère plusieurs maires ont signé
des arrêtés pour permettre l'ouverture
de leur commerce mon essentiel
ce n'est évidemment pas la bonne
solution et nous n'appelons pas à la
désobéissance
vous avez reconnu l'efficacité du binôme
préfet maire dans la gestion de la crise
poursuivi monsieur le premier ministre
dans cette direction fait confiance aux
préfets des départements qui en
concertation avec les maires sont ronds
prendre des arrêtés pertinent et faire
respecter les indispensables contraintes
sanitaires dans le petit commerce
vous savez 4 mètres carrés dans une
grande surface équivaut à 4 mètres
carrés dans un petit commerce il ya
urgence monsieur le premier ministre il
faut revoir votre copie
le groupe socialiste et apparentés vous
a fait deux propositions dimanche sans
sacrifier la nôtre santé qui reste notre
priorité
vous pouvez sauver les commerces et des
centres bourgs et des centre ville en
les autorisant ouvrir avec des
protocoles sanitaires renforcés et vous
devez dans le plfr 4 instauré une taxe
exceptionnelle sur que les la parole est
à monsieur bruno le maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la relance
madame pires bonne je crois que vous
pourrez reconnaître que avec le premier
ministre nous avons eu l'humilité de
corriger notre copie quand nous avons vu
que les petits commerçants estimait
qu'il y avait deux poids deux mesures
nous avons pris toutes les décisions
nécessaires pour garantir l'équilibré
entre les grandes surfaces qu'elles les
français doivent pouvoir continuer à
avoir accès pour se nourrir pauvre accès
à des produits de première nécessité et
les petits commerces et depuis lundi je
ne cesse de recevoir à la demande de
jean castex l'ensemble des commerces qui
sont concernés j'ai reçu ce matin la
fédération des coiffeurs
j'ai reçu la fédération des jouets nous
recevrons la fédération de l'habillement
de recevront avec alain griset tout au
long de la semaine
l'ensemble des fédérations pour voir
exactement comme vous le proposez madame
thérèse bonneau dans quelles conditions
de sécurité sanitaire et à quelles
conditions nous pourrions à partir de la
date qui a fixé le président la
république envisager la réouverture d'un
certain nombre de commerces de proximité
en garantissant la sécurité sanitaire
des français s'agissant de lits commerce
très simplement rappeler une chose parce
que vous n'avez tout ce que amazon à la
bouche et je vous remercie de faire dans
cet hémicycle la publicité d'amazon
serait simplement dire qu'il ne
représente que 20% du commerce en ligne
et qu'il reste 80% du commerce en ligne
je veux bien que vous taxi et le
commerce en ligne
mais dans ce cas là c'est le commerce
français que vous allez taxer demain il
me paraît plus intéressant de faire
exactement ce que cette majorité a eu
l'honneur de faire être la première
nation en europe a taxé les géants du
digital que ce soit google que ce soit
amazon que ce soit facebook que je sois
microsoft parce que là et la justice est
là et l'efficacité
merci monsieur le ministre s'il vous
plaît la parole et aval à marie george
buffet à elle seule
hier des millions d'enfants
d'adolescents de professeurs d'agents de
l'éducation nationale des collectivités
ont repris le chemin de l'école de la
république c'est un témoignage fort de
leur attachement à l'école publique et
laïque
c'est aussi à travers cette minute de
silence une multitude qui a dit sa
confiance dans l'éducation face à tous
les obscurantismes sa confiance dans
l'apprentissage des connaissances comme
source d'émancipation humaine et sociale
oui avec leurs inquiétudes mais aussi
leur colère ils étaient là ils ont
répondu présent conscient que la
fermeture des écoles aggraver les
inégalités sociales entraîné des retards
dans les apprentissages des cas de
malnutrition ou des troubles psychiques
l'ensemble des auditions menées par la
commission d' enquête sur les
conséquences du pot vite sur l'enfance
et la jeunesse le podium elle confirme
aussi le sentiment d'abandon de la
communauté éducative
si l'école doit rester ouverte encore
faut-il garantir aux élèves et aux
équipes pédagogiques des conditions
matérielles et sanitaires suffisantes
pour étudier et enseigner en sécurité au
sens plein alors que la france est
marquée par des tensions extrêmes
cela nécessite que les enseignants
puissent enfin avoir le temps de les
changes qu'il qu'elle soit mieux écouter
notre étoile a besoin de nous leur
fassions confiance en leur donnant les
moyens de remplir leur mission
monsieur le ministre quelles mesures
allez vous prendre pour permettre aux
équipes pédagogiques dans chaque
établissement de france de dialoguer de
proposer allez-vous dédoubler les
classes notamment en collèges ou lycées
afin de respecter les consignes
sanitaires au mieux quelles réponses
concrètes humaines et matérielles
apporterez vous en matière de formation
d'accompagnement de salaires et de
conditions de travail aux équipes
pédagogiques qui ont plus que jamais
besoin de la revalorisation de leur
métier d'école est notre bien commun
nous en sommes tous et toutes comptable
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur jean michel blanquer ministre
de l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
et des sports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés la députée
marie-george buffet d'abord merci pour
votre question pleine de dignité et qui
laisse voir par les objectifs partagés
que nous avons que l'on peut en effet
faire face à cette crise sur le plan
scolaire dès lors qu'on a des objectifs
partagés et le la commission que vous
coprésider joue évidemment un rôle
important dans ce sens plusieurs
plusieurs éléments de réponse et dont
des éléments récents d'ailleurs
premièrement sur la préparation de la
rentrée et j'en profite pour le dire je
rappelle que nous avons créé 1800 postes
à l'école primaire alors qu'il y avait
cinquante mille élèves de moins en cette
rentrée
ça nous a permis de poursuivre le
dédoublement des classes
aujourd'hui nous avons plus de trois
cent vingt mille élèves en cp anciens
qui sont concernés et même en grande
section de maternelle
nous avons mis en oeuvre plus d'un
million cinq cent mille heures
supplémentaires dans le second degré
notamment pour l'opération devoirs faits
et pour l'aide personnalisée aux élèves
nous nous sommes donc préparés à suivre
les élèves qui en avaient le plus besoin
sur le plan pédagogique or justement
nous commençons à voir le résultat des
évaluations de cp et de ce1 de 6e et de
secondes aussi qui nous permet de voir
où en sont les élèves et ce qu'ils ont
perdu ou pas au moment du confinement et
donc d'avoir une aide personnalisée
qualitative avec des moyens que nous
avons mis derrière pour les aider je
communiquerai très prochainement les
résultats de ces évaluations
ce sera vraiment évidemment extrêmement
intéressant je précise que nous sommes
le seul pays au monde qui réussit à
évaluer chacun des élèves d'une corde
c'est à dire huit cent mille enfants par
par classe d'âge pour le faire sur sur
la question du du dédoublement en lice
et aujourd'hui nous avons un protocole
de continuité pédagogique de sorte qu'il
est possible pour un lycée d'avoir des
aménagements permettant l'enseignement à
distance
je rappelle que depuis la rentrée nous
avons été capables d'assurer cette
continuité pédagogique pour chaque école
chaque collège et chaque lycée qui a
fermé ses 0 14% des établissements parce
que précisément notre protocole
sanitaire a permis d'éviter d'en fermer
un programme nombre mais quand ça ferme
nous sommes capables de le faire
nous sommes capables de nous aménager
donc où il y a eu à d'habitation et oui
je partage vos objectifs pour l'intérêt
général d
enfants français merci monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à madame géraldine banier
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à la ministre de la culture
madame la ministre la nécessité absolue
de contrer le virus
quoi qu'il en coûte disait le président
de la république en mars dernier ne fait
pas et ne doit pas faire débat
au lendemain de l'hommage rendu par nos
élèves et la nation à samuel pâtit ce
professeur d'histoire qui aimait les
livres pour transmettre à ses élèves
comme à ses proches la passion de la
connaissance le goût de la liberté
je voudrais revenir sur l'émoi provoqué
par la fermeture de nos librairies dans
l'ensemble du secteur mais aussi chez
nos concitoyens sur l'incompréhension
aussi les mesures mises en place lors du
précédent confinement protocole
sanitaire limitation du nombre de
clients click and collect n'ont elles
pas montré qu'il était possible à chacun
de continuer en toute sécurité à accéder
à cette nourriture essentielle cas
toujours été que sera toujours le livre
les événements de nice d'autriche nous
incite plus que jamais à promouvoir
l'ouverture la pensée de l'autre à la
réflexion à l'étude lumière
indispensable dans la lutte contre
l'obscurantisme et que diffuse
incessamment et sans bruit
les livres afin de ne pas créer de
concurrence déloyale il a été demandé à
la grande distribution d'interdire
l'accès à ces rayons culturel ce que
l'on peut comprendre au nom de l'équité
néanmoins il est difficile pour les
lecteurs de constater qu'ils ne peuvent
plus acheter de livres sinon via des
plateformes bien connu quand les autres
quand les ordinateurs restent eux des
biens de première nécessité utile il est
vrai pour le télétravail et des courants
distant ciel l'impatience est donc réel
elle s'aiguise al'approche des fêtes de
fin d'année où l'on prend plaisir à
choisir offrira ses proches de beaux
livres les salons manifestations
publiques ne sont plus là pour faciliter
la vente directe les professionnels
auteurs éditeurs libraires bien que très
conscient de l'urgence sanitaire et de
la flambée indiscutable des chiffres
sont inquiets quid donc des mesures qui
pourraient être à nouveau mise en place
mais aussi de la réduction annoncée des
tarifs postaux qui permettra à chaque
lecteur de se faire livrer à moins
coup c'est indispensable qu'est le livre
y compris par les librairies de
proximité merci madame la députée la
parole pas valable roselyne bachelot
ministre de la culture madame géraldine
banier nous connaissons votre
militantisme en faveur du livre puisque
vous êtes présidente du groupe d'études
sur le livre ce n'est pas de gaieté de
coeur que nous avons pris ces mesures
les chiffres vous les connaissez le
ministre de la santé le rappelle c'est
un malade
dioko vite toutes les deux secondes une
hospitalisation toutes les 30 secondes
et un mort toutes les quatre minutes
c'est un crève coeur que d'avoir dû
prendre un certain nombre de mesures de
sauvegarde de la santé de nos
concitoyens mais je veux redire de façon
forte qu'on peut acheter des livres et
qu'on peut acheter des livres chez nos
libraires de proximité et que c'est là
qu'ils pourront les acheter
les grands lecteurs les lecteurs assidus
achètent en moyenne un livre par mois
oui on peut acheter ce livre tous les
mois
chez les libraires de proximité par la
méthode du clic et emporter de grâce
n'utilisait pas le mot click and collect
du clic et de cliquer emporté on peut
téléphoner à son libraire
on peut lui faire sms on achète un libre
et ce livre on peut l'acheter grâce
aussi aux mesures que nous allons
prendre parce que les libraires nous les
soutenons nous les soutenons on ne
comptabilisera pas dans les mesures qu'a
préconisé bruno le maire
on ne comptabilisera pas les ventes à
distance et les ventes à cliquer emporté
nous aidons à numériser à digitaliser
nos librairies
il faut qu'ils puissent concurrencer les
plateformes numériques
et puis vous l'avez signalé
nous allons avoir à tarifs préférentiels
sur les envois postaux
nous sommes en train de bâtir cela avec
la poste avec bruno le maire nous
diviserons au minimum et peut-être plus
les tarifs postaux par trois oui nous
soutenons nos libraires acheter des
livres chez vos libraires
merci madame la ministre
la parole est à madame valérie barabara
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
choisi un confinement allégé pour
permettre à l'activité économique de se
poursuivre autant que possible ce que
nous saluons mais dans ce contexte votre
décision de fermer l'ensemble des
commerces de proximité dit non
alimentaire est incompréhensible et
profondément injuste
je vous le dis avec gravité par cette
décision inconsidérée
juste avant noël vous êtes en train de
tuer les petits commerçants de notre
pays et de dérouler le tapis rouge à
amazon
tout le monde s'accorde sur l'impérieuse
nécessité de protéger les français et de
freiner le virus mais la fermeture des
commerces est inefficace et totalement
disproportionnée
pourquoi serait on en effet plus
vulnérables dans une librairie que dans
un métro bondé nos commerçants sont
parfaitement responsable est prête à
renforcer encore davantage les
protocoles sanitaires si nécessaire je
pense un système de vente sur
rendez-vous ou une attestation par
personne et par six semaines pour se
rendre dans ces commerces
les commerçants ne demandait pas des
nouvelles interdictions comme votre
fermeture des rayons non alimentaires
des supermarchés une réponse perdante
pour tout le monde mais de pouvoir
ouvrir leur commerce pour pouvoir
travailler en france plus personne ne
pourra désormais vendre de livres à par
amazon quelle absurdité l'allemagne la
suisse la belgique l'autriche n'ont pas
fermer leur commerce de proximité
j'ai été commerçante je pense aux
bijoutiers aux coiffeurs aux libraires
aux esthéticiennes ou fleuriste aux
boutiques de prêt-à-porter et tant
d'autres
de ces commerces de proximité qui sont
indispensables dans nos territoires et
dont la survie est aujourd'hui menacé
ils sont prêtes à s'adapter à redoubler
d'efforts pour protéger leurs clients
mais ils ne veulent pas mourir
la promesse du gouvernement de
réexaminer la situation dans quinze
jours est une perte de temps
le click'n'rock colette ne suffira pas
admettez votre erreurs et permettait aux
commerces de proximité du thé la parole
est à monsieur bruno le maire ministre
de l'économie des finances et de la
relance madame la députée je le voudrais
saluer l'esprit de responsabilité de
votre réponse de votre question et
l'esprit de responsabilité de
l'association des maires de france 2
françois baroin d'andré laignel qui
plutôt que d'appeler à prendre des
arrêtés illégaux ont fait des
propositions et on fait comme vous
suggérer des avancées pour le commerce
de proximité
c'est comme ça que nous arriverons
ensemble à conjuguer la lutte contre la
circulation du virus et la réouverture
des commerces de proximité à laquelle
croyez-moi nous aspirons tous comment
est-ce que nous allons procéder d'abord
nous allons recevoir gelé a indiqué
toute la semaine
l'ensemble des fédérations de commerce
et croyez moi chacun dans une situation
qui est très différente
les coiffeurs par exemple estiment que
le mois de novembre n'est peut-être pas
prioritaire pour eux ces discussions que
j'ai eues avec eux ce matin la
fédération des vendeurs de jouets bien
entendu estime que le mois de novembre
chaque semaine comptait cinq semaines
est prioritaire parce qu'on approche de
noël
comme l'a rappelé la ministre de la
culture s'agissant des libraires la
question de la prise en charge des frais
postaux pour les livres qui seraient
envoyés par les libraires indépendants
c'est absolument vital et avec roselyne
bachelot nous mettrons cela en place
dans les jours qui viennent
à la demande du premier ministre sur ces
bases là d'ici la fin de la semaine
début de semaine prochaine nous pourrons
avoir des protocoles sanitaires
renforcés pour l'ensemble des commerces
de proximité et nous avons fixé un
rendez vous avec le premier ministre
novembre le 12 novembre nous verrons
quels commerces peuvent rouvrir dans
quelles conditions pour garantir à la
fois soit je sais que vous êtes attaché
madame la députée la sécurité sanitaire
des français est également le
renforcement du commerce de proximité
dans l'intervalle croyez moi nous ne
ménagerons aucun soutien financier pour
permettre à nos commerces de proximité
de passer dans les meilleures conditions
possibles
cette période difficile merci monsieur
le ministre
la parole est un monsieur gérard le seul
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre la situation est d'une
gravité extrême et vos déclarations en
attestent
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
voté jeudi dernier avec le groupe
socialiste apparentés wilairot
confinement en responsabilité en colère
comme nous l'avons déjà dit et surtout
parce qu'il faut mettre la santé des
français
au dessus de toute considération oui
parce qu'il faut tout faire pour enrayer
cette crise sanitaire et la mécanique
infernale de l'épidémie tout faire pour
soulager nos soignants réarmer l'hôpital
public qui vivent à vivre des prochains
jours très éprouvant mais pour que ce
confinement ce recours finement
fonctionne il faut de la transparence de
la clarté de la cohérence de la justice
sociale et des mesures fortes
ce sont les conditions nécessaires pour
assurer d'acceptabilité sociale
essentielle à sa réussite sans
acceptabilité sociale
rien ne sera possible il nous faut la
confiance et le concours de tous les
français il faut de la transparence de
la méthode d'abord la gestion de la
crise sanitaire semble bien mieux
maîtrisé dans plusieurs pays et à chaque
fois la recette est identique tout
mettre sur la table avec des indicateurs
précis ce que nous avons demandé à
plusieurs reprises et des plans d'action
suivi à la lettre de la clarté et de la
cohérence ensuite pour faire cesser la
proxima sion du gouvernement et le
climat anxiogène qui règne aujourd'hui
les enseignants qui ont fait leur
rentrée hier ont attendu jusqu'à
dimanche pour connaître les modalités
des horaires de rentrée ce matin le
porte parole du gouvernement annonce un
couvre feu
il est démentie heureusement rapidement
après de la justice de la concertation
enfin
entre l'essentiel et le non essentiels
des produits commerciaux la ligne qui se
dessine est celle du doigt mouillé
depuis l'annnonce delà de leur fermeture
administrative jeudi dernier les
commerçants et de nombreux artisans ont
crié à la justicia l'inéquité les
arrêtés ont été pris ils sont bien sûr
illégaux ils sont surtout révélateur du
malaise de nos collectivités locales
comment comptez vous monsieur le premier
ministre
réhabiliter la confiance dans votre
parole monsieur le député la parole est
à monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
député gérard le seul d'être le second
députés du groupe socialiste a interrogé
le gouvernement depuis le début de cette
séance de questions au gouvernement
la première députée socialiste qui a
interrogé s'interrogeait justement pour
savoir pourquoi est ce qu'on a fait
fermer les commerces jugeant que la
mesure n'était peut-être pas adapté
monsieur le député
semaine après semaine le moment de cesse
que de venir devant le parlement en
demandant à chacun de mettre sa pierre à
l'édifice de la lutte contre le combat
de la lutte contre l'épidémie à
coronavirus et d'identifier les
propositions qui pourraient être de
nature à freiner la diffusion du virus
monsieur le député systématiquement
lorsque des mesures ont été prises par
le gouvernement ou par le parlement voté
même par le parlement systématiquement
ou presque
un certain nombre de groupes
d'opposition sont venus en tribune de
l'assemblée dire que c'était
irresponsable non préparés que ça ne
serait pas efficace
ce député vous parlez des clés de la
confiance à donner à la population à
cette période cruciale de notre histoire
collective
je vous renvoie la question monsieur
débuté quelle est la part de confiance
que les uns et les autres nous pouvons
apporter à travers une unité nationale
dans la prise de décisions qui sont
nécessaires et s'il vous fallait des
preuves supplémentaires sont tellement
nécessaire qu'elles sont prises par la
plupart de nos voisins européens est
qu'elles sont même prises par des pays à
travers les autres de l'autre côté des
différents océans du monde
à mesure que le virus peut progresser
monsieur le député ce n'est pas la faute
de la france si melbourne était confiné
pendant trois mois si israël a confiné
pendant deux mois si le japon était
confiné si la belgique et les pays bas
sont confinés si le pays de galles c'est
l'irlande
monsieur le député partout des mesures
ont été prises qui vise à freiner les
contacts
ic entre les gens pour freiner la
diffusion du virus ce n'est pas une
solution franco française c'est une
solution mondiale déjà appliquée dans la
plupart des pays du monde
une fois deux fois voire trois fois dans
certains pays alors accompagné nous a
expliqué la nécessité de ces mesures
accompagnez nous pour donner confiance
aux français accompagnez nous pour nous
aider dans la lutte contre le virus et
vous rendre elle a aussi un grand
service aux soignants qui attend de la
représentation nationale qu'elle soit
pleinement consciente de ce qu'il
traverse en ce moment pour sauver des
vies dans les hôpitaux
merci monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à monsieur jean marie
sermier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre notre collègue valérie
base à malgrat vous a fait part du
désarroi des commerçants de france
ils ont fait des efforts considérables
pour respecter les protocoles sanitaires
et protéger leurs clients ils l'ont fait
avec succès puisque aucun kloster n'a
été signalé dans les magasins à quelques
semaines de noël
il ne supporte pas de devoir baisser
rideau et de laisser le champ libre à
amazon concurrent déloyal contre lequel
vous ne proposez rien actuellement il
faut soutenir nos commerçants nos
artisans locaux je pense par exemple aux
coiffeurs aux auto écoles
pour cela des maires ont pris des
arrêtés autorisant l'ouverture des
commerces
ce sont des lanceurs d'alert c'est un
acte symbolique c'est un appel
or nous avons lu avec stupéfaction
samedi un communiqué de presse de la rs
bourgogne franche comté par l'enjeu site
de polémiques consternante et d'arrêter
manifestement clientéliste monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
il est inacceptable de sortir à ce point
du principe de neutralité de
l'administration
il est insupportable que des hauts
fonctionnaires insulte les élus locaux
maillon essentiel de notre république a
priori pendant cette crise sanitaire
monsieur le premier ministre condamnez
vous ce communiqué de presse
nous avons tous conscience de la gravité
de la situation il faut se battre sans
relâche contre le virus
il faut protéger les français mais il
faut le faire dans la justice et
l'efficacité
il est temps que le gouvernement admette
son échec du déconfinement et son
impréparation dur confinement il faut
revoir
d'urgence le dispositif nous avons fait
des propositions à l'image des marchés
lors du premier confinement nous
proposons que les préfets en
concertation étroite avec les maires
puissent accorder des dérogations au
commerce
bien évidemment lorsqu'il respecte le
protocole sanitaire
monsieur le premier ministre allez vous
enfin faire voter l'amendement des
républicains pour mettre en place cette
mesure
merci monsieur les buts et la parole et
à monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur
monsieur le député ça fait plusieurs
semaines que vous interpeller les uns
les autres le gouvernement disant quand
est-ce que vous prendrez des mesures
pour protéger les français
nous mettons en place des mesures pour
protéger les français et vous ne
répondez à non pas celle là
ah non pas celle là ah non pas celle là
ensuite vous nous dites consulter les
élus pour prendre des décisions nous
consultons les élus nous prenons des
décisions
les élus certains une infime minorité
d'élus décide d'attaquer les décisions
et vous dites ils ont raison d'attaquer
la décision et ensuite vous allez nous
dire où est la cohérence
où est la cohérence dans les décisions
qui sont prises monsieur le député
monsieur député monsieur le député
pouvez vous douté une seconde de la
volonté du gouvernement de soutenir ces
commerces qu'ils soient de commerce de
proximité ou de commerce en général
pouvez vous douté une seconde de la
volonté du gouvernement de soutenir
l'éducation des enfants et des jeunes et
des étudiants
pouvez vous douté une seconde de la
volonté du gouvernement de soutenir son
économie et en même temps d'être capable
de protéger les français
alors si comme moi vous ne doutez pas du
bon sens qui anime ce gouvernement ne
doutez pas des mesures qui sont prises
elles sont prises parce qu'elles sont
nécessaires
ce ne sont pas les commerçants qui sont
responsables de la circulation du virus
responsables de la situation épidémique
en revanche messieurs les députés
monsieur le député en revanche on sait
très bien il a été démontré en france à
l'étranger que plus on restreint les
possibilités de sortie rando là dessus
au delà de ce qui est essentiel
plus on va limiter les contacts
physiques et plus on va freiner la
diffusion du virus
si nous ne prenons pas ces mesures non
seulement nous aurons des morts beaucoup
de malades
beaucoup de familles en détresse des
hôpitaux saturation mais je peux vous
garantir que le pays ne retrouverait pas
une activité économique et sociale
normale avant très longtemps
ces mesures sont nécessaires nous vous
demandons les accompagner à l'assemblée
nationale et comme sur les territoires
en responsabilité merci monsieur lui un
peu de calme s'il vous plaît la parole
est aux madame bénédicte peut-elle merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
ministre
l'épidémie de kobe 19 nous touche tous
directement ou indirectement elle nous
touche à travers la perte d'un être cher
l'admission d'un proche en réanimation
les séquelles avec lesquels un proche
doit réapprendre à vivre
nous sommes tous concernés les
témoignages des soignants ne cesse de
nous alerter sur la réalité de la
situation
nous les applaudissent y ont tous les
soirs à 20h pendant le premier
confinement à juste titre je peux
témoigner de leur professionnalisme de
leur dévouement et de leur humanité
quand ils ont des soigner mes parents à
bichat et à la pitié
nous devons aujourd'hui plus que jamais
les écouter comme l'a dit mon collègue
les
gérard le seul les soutenir car nous
sommes tous conscients que leurs
conditions de travail sont extrêmement
difficiles et ce soutien passe avant
tout par la prise en compte de leurs
propos quand ils font part de la réalité
du terrain au quotidien
cette réalité est la suivante vous
l'avez dit madame la ministre de la
culture
aujourd'hui le kobe 10 lakovic 19 c'est
plus de 50 mille nouveaux cas de
contamination recensés en 24 heures
jamais depuis le début de l'épidémie la
france en avait enregistré autant c'est
un malade toutes les deux secondes une
hospitalisation toutes les 30 secondes
et un mort toutes les quatre minutes
lakovic 19 c'est une crise sanitaire qui
frappe aussi avant tout les plus
vulnérables d'entre nous les personnes
en situation de précarité
rien qu en ile de france 40% des
personnes sans domicile fixe ont été
infectées les mesures de confinement qui
ont été prises sont difficiles d'où le
rose anxiogène nous en sommes tous
conscients notamment pour l'ag la
jeunesse les tpe les pme ou les
commerçants se sont bien entendu des
mesures que nous aurions tous préféré ne
pas devoir prendre et qui demande à
chacun d'entre nous un certain courage
une forme d' amener gaz fibre la députée
la parole est à monsieur olivier ferrand
ministre des solidarités de la santé
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la députée à travers votre
question de soutenir comme vous venez de
le faire l'ensemble des soignants en
ville et dans nos hôpitaux qui
monsieur le député quand on rend hommage
aux soignants il n'est peut être pas
utile d'interpeller dahmani
madame la députée vous êtes élus de
votre circonscription est comme
l'ensemble des élus ici quand vous
rentrez dans vos territoires respectifs
vous êtes confrontés justement la
souffrance à la détresse de ces
soignants en tout cas à la crainte
qu'ils peuvent émettre et l'engagement
déterminé dont ils font preuve au
quotidien pour sauver des vies et je
suis certain que les soignants de votre
circonscription
comme dans la plupart ou la totalité des
circonscriptions font part alors
parlementaires des inquiétudes qui sont
les leurs et de la volonté qu'ils ont
que nous prenions en responsabilité des
mesures pour freiner la circulation du
virus réduire le nombre de malades et
ainsi sauver des vies ce que nous nous
efforçons à faire madame la députée avec
le soutien important fondamentale même
de l'ensemble des députés de la majorité
réunis dans cette période difficile
encore une fois que notre pays traverse
mais je crois qu'en responsabilité vous
pouvez être fier de porter ce discours
dans les territoires auprès des hôpitaux
de vaud soignants de vos mères de vos
commerçants même si c'est difficile même
si les mesures qui sont prises même si
le confinement entraîne aussi la
détresse chez nombre de français qui
faisait d'ailleurs une activité
professionnelle ou non qu'ils soient
jeunes ou qu'ils soient âgés ce n'est
pas la solution à laquelle chacun
d'entre nous inspirer naturellement mais
c'est une solution qui est nécessaire un
moment d'une épidémie ou le virus
s'emballe le virus est un phénomène
naturel c'est une catastrophe naturelle
qui nous oblige à prendre des mesures
hors du commun et ces mesures je voulais
vous dire madame la députée qui ne tient
qu il tient à chacun de nous de les
respecter de les appliquer ce sont
l'ensemble des français qui sont les
premiers moteurs de la lutte contre ce
virus et les français parce qu ils sont
courageux et parce qu'ils sont là parce
qu'ils sont solidaires réussiront comme
ils l'ont fait au printemps dernier a
terrassé ce virus
la parole est à monsieur loïc
prud'hommes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'économie
nous sommes aujourd'hui face à un
gouffre du fait de l'improvisation
totale de votre gouvernement et son
incapacité à anticiper depuis plus de
huit mois
ce n'est pas faute de vous avoir alerté
d'avoir déposé 11 proposition de loi
rédigée 5 rapports et quatre guides
d'avoir mené une commission denquête
pour planifier une trajectoire de sortie
de crise et éviter d'y sombrer à nouveau
mais vous n'avez rien voulu entendre
vous avez juste réussi à nous mener au
bord du ko sanitaires et économiques aux
commerçants qui pose la question de la
continuité de leur activité
je dis ceci si nous étions gouvernement
vous pourriez à 7h accueillir dans vos
magasins deux ou trois clients avec le
protocole strict que vous avez déjà mis
en oeuvre
précédemment et contrairement à ce que
va répondre le ministre dans quelques
secondes et comme il l'a déjà fait c'est
bien moins risqué sanitairement que de
s'entasser à 20 dans les rayons des
supermarchés par dizaines dans les
transports dans des classes et des
restaurants scolaires
vous êtes attentif à la sécurité
sanitaire de vos clients
les irresponsables ce sont eux qui vous
ont déjà abandonné une première fois
lors de la bataille pour vos pertes
d'exploitation face aux assureurs privés
vorace qui verse encore des dividendes
oui il y en a assez des profiteurs de
crise dont on attend qu'il soit
sévèrement rappelé à leur devoir de
solidarité nationale 14 milliards de
fraude à la tva pour les géants du
e-commerce
d'après les services du ministère de
l'économie et pas un petit doigt n'a été
levée par le ministre artisan commerçant
s'il avait affaire à nous ces géants
seraient taxées dès demain pour dommages
environnementaux et sociaux les
milliards volés par ces profiteurs de
misère serait immédiatement utilisé pour
permettre notre tissu économique de
proximité de passer cette crise monsieur
le ministre
l'économie ce n'est pas que le
portefeuille du pdg d'amazon quand
prendrez-vous les mesures urgentes avant
la fermeture définitive du rideau des
milieux de petits commerces
merci monsieur débuté la parole à
monsieur bruno le maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la relance
monsieur le député vous nous dites que
depuis huit mois que cette crise a
commencé
nous avons fait preuve d'improvisation
en matière économique
depuis huit mois
la france a apporté un soutien sans
faille à son économie depuis huit mois
la france a dégagé 120 milliards d'euros
de prêts garantis par l'état pour éviter
que les entreprises fassent faillite
depuis huit mois la france apporté un
soutien son secteur aéronautique à son
secteur automobile à l'hôtellerie au
café la restauration au tourisme à
l'événementiel au secteur de la culture
depuis huit mois la france et en europe
le pays qui a le mieux protéger le
pouvoir d'achat de ses compatriotes en
apportant un soutien au chômage massif
comme aucun autre pays ne l'a fait à
cette mesure en europe depuis huit mois
la france est tenue aux côtés des petits
commerçants depuis huit mois
la france a mis en place un fonds de
solidarité qui est allé plus généreux de
tous les pays européens pour que les
petits commerçants perdent le moins
possible de leur chiffre d'affaires et
leur moins possible de leurs revenus
depuis un mois à la demande du premier
ministre jean castex et à la demande du
président de la république nous avons
renforcer massivement ses mesures de
soutien au commerce
nous allons dépenser en un mois au mois
de novembre
autant sur le fond de solidarité que
tout ce que nous avions dépensé depuis
le mois de mars
monsieur le député cette majorité et la
république dans son ensemble a apporté
un soutien massif total immédiat notre
économie je ne vous laisserai pas dire
que nous avons laissé tomber l'économie
française alors que nous avons évité des
dizaines de milliers de faillite
des centaines de milliers
licenciement et que c'est le
contribuable français avec l'argent de
son travail qui a permis de sauver
l'économie française
merci monsieur nice
[Applaudissements]
la parole le tavana s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît
la parole est à madame sylvie boucher
bellecour et elle seule merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
et permettez moi d'y associer mon
collègue robert therry en mars dernier
la vague épidémique qui touchait notre
pays avait de quoi surprendre nos
compatriotes et leurs représentants il
est vrai qu'à cette période le
gouvernement navigué à vue tout en
mêlant les injonctions contradictoires
aux français hélas huit mois plus tard
vous n'apprenez toujours pas de vos
erreurs
dès juillet le conseil scientifique vous
alerter sur la très haute probabilité
qu'une deuxième vague épidémique
apparaît cet automne pourtant vous ne
l'avez pas anticipé les chiffres
alarmants publié ce lundi le prouve la
france établit à nouveau recours de 50
2500 cas recensés en 24 heures
vertigineux quand on sait que votre
ministre de la santé affirmait il y a
dix jours que l'épidémie serait
incontrôlable
au delà des 50 mille cas quotidiens
alors oui nous sommes tous conscients
que la maîtrise de l'épidémie est
difficile partout en europe et que
personne ici là deux solutions toutes
faites mais cela n'excuse pas tout et ce
n'est pas simplement la nouvelle députée
que je suis qui vous interpelle mais
l'infirmière aqua beau expliquer aux
français que nous ne rattraperons pas
notre retard en les testant massivement
si aucune stratégie d'isolement est
ensuite mise en place comment justifier
que huit mois plus tard nous n'ayons
toujours pas plus de lits en réanimation
qu'en mars
pourquoi attendre
pourquoi attendre du jour après le début
du confinement pour généraliser les
tests dans les aéroports pourquoi ne pas
tester massivement tous les personnels
des écoles
comme nous vous le demandons monsieur le
ministre vous êtes encore ce matin
obligé de démentir dans leur votre porte
parole qui annonce un couvre-feu à paris
ces tergiversations
ne passez plus chez nos concitoyens qui
vous domaines qui vous demandent des
consignes claires pour les protéger
allez vous enfin accepté d'écouter les
propositions que les députés les
républicains vous formule merci merci
vam la députée
la parole est à monsieur olivier vers
envie d'istres des solidarités et de la
santé madame la députée boucher
bellecour dans votre question vous
émettez un certain nombre de questions
c'est j'ai envie de vous dire discute on
échange on pousse sont un peu les choses
il ya deux questions vous posez vous
dites à caen quand est ce que vous allez
commencer à généraliser les tests
je ne sais pas à madame la députée si
vous entendez par généraliser les tests
2 millions de tests par semaine en test
pcr et est entré chez antigénique y sont
déployées plus de 2 millions de tests
antigénique ont déjà été acquis par les
pharmacies d'officine les médecins les
infirmières libérales des barnums je
sais pas ce que vous entendez par
généraliser les tests mais faites moi
une proposition sans sincérité ça
m'intéresse d'avoir votre proposition
lorsque vous dites quand est-ce que vous
avez testé les personnels des écoles et
bien avec jean michel blanquer r nous
avons tout un protocole justement pour
permettre aux enseignants à tout le
personnel scolaire d'être prioritaire
dans l'accès aux tests pcr fait nouveau
proposition est ce que voulait aller
plus loin dites nous ce que vous
entendez par tester ce contexte tout le
monde
systématiquement tous les jours toutes
les semaines comment est ce qu'on fait
madame madame la députée vous dites que
vous êtes infirmières et soyez la
bienvenue à l'assemblée nationale dans
cet hémicycle
lorsque vous dites n'attendez attendez
je suis ministre
mon cher collègue chers collègues vous
arrêtez de vociférer notre collègue a
posé une question valable est respecté
notre collègue qui a posé une question
et des ministres qui lui répond je vous
donnerai mme la députée dit si on vous
dit comment pourquoi est ce que vous
n'avez pas augmenter les animations
depuis mars à nous les avons augmentés
déjà de 15 % de il augmente
quotidiennement à mesure que les besoins
augmentent
3 nous avons formé près de 10000
soignants aux techniques de réanimation
quatre jeux gouvernement je l'avouer je
le confesse pas toujours pas trouvé le
moyen de former un réanimateur en plus
en moins de dix ans mais si vous avez
des propositions je suis preneur enfin
madame la députée lorsque beau dit
lorsque vous dites
revoyez vos stratégies en matière
d'isolement je vous tend la perche
madame la députée en sincérité si vous
considérez qu'il doit y avoir un débat
démocratique pour faire évoluer le
contrôle des stratégie d'isolement pour
les personnes qui sont au cas positifs
moi je suis tout à fait prêt à en
débattre mais je suis venu cinq fois
dans un débat parlementaire dans le cas
de l'état d'urgence
aborder ces questions là et c'était une
fin de non recevoir de votre groupe
systématiquement donc ma porte est
grande ouverte vous serait la bienvenue
en dehors de cet hémicycle aura
peut-être moins de bruit merci monsieur
le ministre
bien la parole est à madame claire pitot
la merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à la ministre du
travail
jeudi dernier le gouvernement a annoncé
les mesures nécessaires pour protéger
nos concitoyens face à la seconde vague
de l'épidémie de covile cette stratégie
passe avant tout par une protection
accrue des salariés et je tiens à saluer
la réactivité du gouvernement qui a
publié jeudi une nouvelle version du
protocole national pour les entreprises
qui pose le principe du télétravail
total pour les postes compatibles
ces précautions vise avant tout à
protéger la santé des salariés et à
réduire le risque de contamination cela
passe notamment par le désengorgement
des transports en commun ou la
distanciation social est impossible je
tiens par ailleurs à apporter mon
soutien aux entreprises et aux salariés
qui font tout leur possible s'il est
important de développer le télétravail
la différence entre un recours partiel
et un recours total à celui ci est
grande
non le télétravail total n'est pas
facile s'il est indispensable
aujourd'hui pour lutter contre le virus
il rend cependant plus compliqué le
travail en équipe et peut également pour
certains salariés être un facteur
d'isolement social
madame la ministre je vous appelle donc
à veiller très particulièrement aux
conséquences psychologiques de cette
nouvelle organisation du travail
enfin si le déploiement du télétravail
est précipitée par la crise
il s'agit aussi d'accompagner les
entreprises et les salariés dans la
durée c'est une attente forte de nos
concitoyens et l'expérience du
télétravail qui s'ouvre sera
déterminante pour soutenir un réel
changement culturel
je pense notamment à la question
primordiale de l'accès au numérique et
plus particulièrement de la gestion des
données madame la ministre comment le
gouvernement entend accompagner les
entreprises et leurs salariés tout en
tenant compte des difficultés propres à
chaque secteur
comment surtout faire en sorte que ces
mesures difficiles mais nécessaires ne
rime pas avec isolement et pertes de
compétences mais plutôt avec progression
al et innovation journée richard
collègues la parole et à madame
elisabeth bornes ministre du travail de
l'emploi et de l'insertion
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
claire piteux là alors je voudrais
profiter de votre question pour mettre
fin à une contre vérité pour les
entreprises et pour les salariés
le télétravail n'est pas une option
surtout pas quand 416 de nos concitoyens
sont décédés hier de lakovic 19 donc je
voudrais rappeler le principe qui est
désormais inscrit dans le protocole
national en entreprise dans les
circonstances exceptionnelles actuelles
liées à la menace de l'épidémie
le télétravail doit être la règle pour
l'ensemble des activités qui le
permettent
dans ce cadre le temps de travail
effectué en télétravail est porté à 100
% pour les salariés qui peuvent
effectuer l'ensemble de leurs tâches
entre elles et travaille donc j'ai bien
dit 100%
alors j'entends certains dire que les
employeurs ne jouent pas le jeu
je leur réponds que le protocole a été
mis en ligne jeudi soir dernier il
salariés pour une partie d'entre eux
sont rentrés de congé hier matin donc
laissons un minimum de temps aux
entreprises pour s'organiser
c'est une semaine test et avec mes
services nous suivons de très près la
mise en place du télétravail et les
retours sont déjà positif et par
ailleurs pour ceux qui l'ignorent le
code du travail impose à l'employeur de
prendre les mesures nécessaires pour
assurer la sécurité et protéger la santé
de leurs salariés
à ce titre et sur la base du protocole
des employeurs le savent très bien leur
responsabilité pourrait être engagée
donc il ne le souhaite pas et je ne le
souhaite pas non plus donc tous ensemble
respectons le protocole et vous avez
raison madame la députée tout n'est pas
noir ou blanc pour certains salariés
être seul en télétravail cinq jours sur
cinq
ça peut être une source d'angoissé pour
ça que nous allons mettre en place en
complément de ce que font les employeurs
et les organisations syndicales
un numéro vert pour apporter un soutien
psychologique aux salariés qui en ont
besoin
merci merci madame la ministre la parole
est maintenant madame karine le bon roi
qui je souhaite la bienvenue que je
salue et qui succède à notre collègue
ex-collègue hub est une guette bello
merci aux paroles chocolat merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre du
travail
la jeunesse souffre et tout ce qui
pourra atténuer les conséquences de
cette crise sanitaire sur leur vie est
bienvenue mais ces initiatives ne
doivent pas se faire au détriment de la
solidarité entre les générations
ni au prix de divisions familiales ni
non plus pour accentuer une précarité
déjà inquiétante
c'est pourtant ce triple risque que vous
venez de prendre en modifiant les
critères d'attribution des contrats
parcours emploi compétences à la réunion
depuis la mi-octobre les pecs financé
par l'état ne sont éligibles qu'à celles
et ceux qui sont âgés de moins de 26 ans
les répercussions sont immenses pour les
bénéficiaires comme pour les
collectivités et les associations qui
les emploient ni les uns ni les autres
n'ont d'ailleurs été consultés sur ce
bouleversement dans la politique des
contrats cds dans ma circonscription la
commune de saint paul ne pourra selon ce
nouveau critère répondre favorablement
qu'à 20% à peine des demandes déjà
enregistrés et comme la mesure porte
aussi sur les renouvellements le nombre
de personnes qui devront être licenciés
au terme de leur contrat risque
d'exploser dans toutes les communes de
la réunion où la très grande majorité
des bénéficiaires des pecs en plus de 26
ans nous approuvons le dispositif
national
un jeune une solution mais son
application est différenciée peut
conduire à opposer les plus jeunes aux
moins jeunes une solution existe qui est
de débloquer rapidement les 18000
contrats supplémentaires annoncées par
le ministre d outre mer lors de son
passage en août à la réunion ce qui
permettra de proposer des solutions
d'emplois aux moins de 26 ans mais aussi
d'éviter à des milliers de personnes de
se retrouver sans emploi
bref de ne
mettre à mal notre cohésion sociale je
vous remercie merci chers collègues la
parole est à madame elisabeth bornes
ministre du travail de l'emploi et de
l'insertion
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame karine le
bon écoutez madame la députée je vous
souhaite la bienvenue et je voudrais
tout d'abord vous rassurer dans le cadre
du plan un jeune une solution le
gouvernement a décidé de faire un effort
sans précédent en faveur de la jeunesse
mais évidemment cet effort ne se fait
pas au détriment des autres publics
prioritaires et je vous confirme que
notamment pour 2021
nous allons mettre en place 60 mille
parcours emploi compétences
supplémentaires et 50 mille contrats
initiatives emplois supplémentaires au
profit des jeunes
mais par ailleurs dans le cadre du plan
pauvreté le gouvernement a également
décidé de doubler l'effort à 24000
parcours emploi compétences ciblées vers
les quartiers prioritaires de la
politique de la ville où les zones de
revitalisation rurale et donc au final
en 2021 ce sont 122 mille contrats aidés
supplémentaires qui vont être déployés
ces contrats ils doivent bénéficier aux
publics les plus éloignés de l'emploi
constitué des parcours qualitative
d'insertion vers l'emploi
en complément des autres dispositifs
tels que par exemple l'insertion par
l'activité économique
la réunion bénéficiera donc d'une
augmentation substantielle des contrats
aidés
au delà du volume prévu par le plan
priorités et rassemblements pour
l'emploi local à la réunion le plan
pétrels annoncé par le président de la
république en début d'année concernant
la gestion 2020 mais services sont en
train d'examiner les redéploiements qui
pourraient être nécessaires au bénéfice
des régions qui auraient des besoins qui
ne seraient pas encore satisfaits et
donc je vous confirme madame la députée
si notre objectif est de ne laisser
aucun jeune sur le bord de la route cela
ne se fera pas au détriment des autres
publics prioritaires
merci madame la ministre le député merci
pour votre réponse
mais le préfet de la réunion a adressé
une lettre donc aux différents maires
des communes où il dit bien que
c'est parcours emploi compétences sont
réservés aux moins de 26 ans et
aujourd'hui pôle emploi bloque les
demandes
donc c'est pour ça que se pose la
question merci madame la députée madame
la ministre
bon la parole est à monsieur guillaume
garot
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la santé nous l'avons tous
compris la deuxième vague du coc vite
pourrait être plus haute que la première
chacun c'est ici que affronter une crise
de cette ampleur est difficile et on le
voit partout ailleurs en europe
la solution je veux le dire elle dépend
d'abord de chacun de nous pour respecter
les consignes sanitaires respecte on
l'est pour épargner nos soignants qui
ont besoin de notre soutien
c'est vrai mais qui ont aussi besoin de
moyens
monsieur le ministre le 14 juillet le
président de la république nous disait
nous serons prêts fin août le premier
ministre
jean castex nous disait la même chose
manifestement on est au mois de novembre
et on n'y est pas monsieur le ministre
où sont les 12 miss place de réanimation
que vous annonciez le 27 août dernier
monsieur le ministre où sont les 4000
lits supplémentaires à la demande que
vous annonciez en conclusion du ségur de
la santé
les soignants font leur maximum mais
l'état aussi doit faire son maximum nous
le devons aux soignants et nous le
devons aux français à situation
exceptionnelle mesure exceptionnelle
pour ouvrir les lits qui manquent pour
former sans attendre ce qu'ils
pourraient être mobilisés pour
revaloriser fortement et rapidement les
rémunérations des soignants et attirer
de nouveau les aides-soignants les
infirmières
quitter l'hôpital au fil du temps les
183 euros n'ont pas suffit monsieur le
ministre alors les soignants monsieur
ministre mérite davantage que des
applaudissements
que comptez vous faire pour que dans
l'urgence où nous sommes les actes
suivent
merci monsieur le député la parole à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé merci
monsieur le député pour votre message de
responsabilité qui consiste à appeler
les français à être solidaire dans la
période être courageux fort soudés pour
pouvoir respecter les mesures sanitaires
et lutter avec efficacité contre
l'épidémie m'interroger sur les mesures
hospitalière monsieur le député le plfss
le budget de la sécurité sociale a été
voté par une majorité parlementaire la
semaine dernière et il porte en lui
exactement les réponses auxquelles vous
appeler monsieur député hélas le groupe
socialiste a voté contre
mais comme on dit il ya une chance au
grattage une chance au tirage en
deuxième lecture qui arrivera il ne
tient qu'à vous de voter il ne tient
qu'à vous de voter les 8 milliards
d'euros de hausses de salaires pour près
de 2 millions de soignants dans nos
hôpitaux et nos ehpad
nous n'avons pas voté il ne tient qu'à
vous de voter la création les 50
millions d'euros pour déployer les 4000
lits à la demande
vous n'avez pas voté mais rassurez vous
ces 4000 lits sont bien en cours d'être
déployé dans tous les hôpitaux qui sont
utiles et chaque à vous de voter leur
bouche de 15000 soignants
supplémentaires dans les hôpitaux comme
l'avait demandé s'ils étaient engagés le
le premier ministre jean castex et puis
il ne tient qu'à vous de voter les 2.5
milliards d'euros supplémentaires de
budget pour les hôpitaux les 13
milliards d'euros de reprise de tête
les 6 milliards d'euros
d'investissements pour les hôpitaux rue
pour les ehpad le grand plan numérique
qui a été présenté et bientôt vous aurez
l'occasion de voter une proposition
parlementaire qui j'espère fera
consensus qui vise à changer la
gouvernance des hôpitaux pour la
simplifier pour donner plus de place à
chacun dans les décisions hospitalière
qui sont prises pour renforcer la
territorialité le lien avec les élus
dans l'ensemble des territoires
nous sommes en train de faire évoluer
l'hôpital monsieur débuter vous avez
raison de souligner c'est juste trop de
fermetures de lits trop de suppressions
de postes année après année autrèche
dire décennie après décennie constater
avec nous que non seulement la donne a
changé mes comptes va bien au delà du
tweet et de la peine à changer les
choses nous le faisons et vous avez
encore la capacité de le voter avec nous
merci monsieur liste la parole est à
monsieur nicolas turquois merci monsieur
le président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la relance c'est un député en colère
qui vous parle
une nouvelle fois le châtelleraudais
dans la vienne est touché au coeur cette
fois ci c'est la filiale avionique de
thales qui annonce 998 suppressions de
postes dont 258 pour le seul territoire
de châtellerault il faut y ajouter la
suppression de plus d'une centaine de
postes d'intérimaires au final ce sont
au moins 220 familles qui vont être
impactés durement 220 familles qui se
rajoute aux 300 des fonderies du poitou
qui sont sur la sellette et aux plus de
200 qui font l'objet d'un pse chez
mcafee a sous traitants de
l'aéronautique
monsieur le ministre comment un groupe
de l'envergure de thales avec
l'importance des dispositifs de soutien
et notamment l'appel des peut faire des
annonces de cette ampleur la crise
d'etel pas utilisé pour faire des
restructurations qui était déjà dans les
cartons
certes on nous annonce le transfert de
deux lignes de soutien sur des
équipements du rafale mais l'état
actionnaire peut-il accepter qu'un seul
et même territoire doivent à lui seul
accepter de tels sacrifices
il est indispensable que ce territoire
comme beaucoup d'autres en france
bénéficient de l'accompagnement du plan
de relance mais les entreprises qui sont
présentes ne savent pas à de très rares
exceptions près comment s'approprier les
possibilités offertes par ce plan
les appels à projets sont trop complexes
pour des pme dans le contexte économique
actuel
si on n'y prend garde le plan de relance
ne va aider qu'une poignée d'entre elles
et va de ce fait ne concentrait ses
effets que sur les territoires déjà les
plus innovants
ce sont pourtant les territoires les
plus fragiles qu'il faut accompagner en
priorité alors que ce soit sur thales ou
sur les territoires industriels
fragilisé pourriez vous monsieur le
ministre nous expliquer comment le
gouvernement compte procéder
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
mme olivia grégoire secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'économie sociale solidaire
et responsable
monsieur le député turquois oui le
groupe thales si vous le savez confronté
à une crise qui frappe globalement le
secteur aérien
un chiffre d'affaires global au
troisième trimestre en baisse de 10% par
rapport à l'année dernière mais surtout
plus de 45% dans le seul domaine de
l'aéronautique civile l'entreprise à
l'instar de beaucoup de sociétés du
secteur a donc pris un certain nombre de
mesures d'adaptation des effectifs et
des coûts qui permet de traverser cette
crise nous le savons et vous l'avez dit
ces mesures sont douloureuses jeu
néanmoins qu'on salue et je crois que
vous l'avez fait aussi l' annonce faite
par thales de transférer à châtellerault
une ligne de réparation de nars de
nacelles militaire qui permet de sauver
a minima 70 emplois sur site
oui 188 emplois sont encore menacées ce
chiffre est élevé
il aurait pu l'être pardonnez moi de le
rappeler mais encore plus sans la mise
en oeuvre des dispositifs de soutien de
la puissance publique notamment
l'activité partielle de longue durée
dont thales a choisi de faire usage
au-delà de l'émotion légitime que vous
portez mais je suis le député turquois
et que je suscite une telle annonce pour
le bassin d'emploi de châtellerault je
crois que c'est une démarche responsable
si que de regarder en face la réalité
économique d'un secteur et de prendre
les mesures nécessaires pour préserver
l'outil industriel
nous le faisons aujourd'hui avec le
dispositif d'activité partielle de
longue durée nous le faisons aussi dans
le cadre du plan de soutien annoncé le 9
juin dernier et nous continuerons de le
faire pour une industrie aéronautique
verte et compétitive um interrogé par
ailleurs sur un sujet très important sur
le déploiement du plan de relance à leur
endroit des petites moyennes entreprises
et des entreprises de taille
intermédiaire je veux vous dire que son
déploiement est une réalité que les pme
les hôtes et ea s'en empare sur les 1800
dossiers qui ont déjà été déposés sur
les appels à projets 70 % viennent des
pme et des eti
la proportion est la même pour les 350
dossiers lauréats monsieur turquois si
des complexités vous l'avez dit continue
de vous être remonté nous sommes là pour
simplifier encore et toujours s'il faut
le faire encore plus je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre je veux donner
la parole à monsieur bernard boulet qui
a succédé au mois d'août monsieur franck
marlin et que je suis heureux de saluer
vous avez la parole chers collègues
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues
ma question est à l'attention de
monsieur le ministre des solidarités et
de la santé
monsieur le ministre par un communiqué
publié le mardi 13 octobre 2020 votre
ministère a donné le coup d'envoi à la
campagne de vaccination contre la grippe
saisonnière
vous vous engagiez à fournir les
pharmacies tout au long de la campagne
vient l'approvisionnement continu auprès
des laboratoires pharmaceutiques
vous avez ensuite communiquer en grande
pompe autour de cette campagne de
vaccination les français vous ont
entendu et le demandent qu'à se faire
vacciner contre la grippe saisonnière
mais ils n'y parviennent pas la vérité
c'est que les stocks de vaccins sont
très insuffisants même les soignants
pourtant exposé à des personnes fragiles
ne peuvent souvent pas se faire vacciner
dix jours après le lancement de la
campagne de vaccination contre la grippe
70 à 80% des pharmacies étaient en
rupture de stock en particulier dans les
grandes villes
après la pénurie des masques puis la
pénurie des tests pendant la crise
sanitaire
voici hélas la pénurie de vaccins contre
la grippe
ce manque d'anticipation chronique se
répète se répète hélas encore une fois
les français ont été désignés
responsables de la son goût de la
seconde vague de lakovic 19 pour ne pas
avoir suffisamment appliqués les gestes
barrière c'est vrai que c'était plus
facile que de reconnaître l'échec de
votre déconfinement et votre incapacité
augmenter le nombre de livres de réel
l'action lorsque la tâche des soignants
seront encore aggravée par l'afflux de
malades de la grippe saisonnière
reprochera ton à ces derniers de ne pas
s'être fait vacciner c'est les soignants
sont tous et au lit par la grippe
la lutte contre la maladie sera encore
plus compliqué tout cela laisse présager
le pire lorsque sera enfin venu le temps
de lancer une campagne de vaccination
contre la copie de 19
les français sont en droit de savoir
combien de temps cette pénurie est
inconcevable du roi je vous le demande
donc monsieur le ministre quand cette
incurie cessera-t-elle la parole et à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
député boulet mais s'est laissé moi de
vous souhaiter la bienvenue à
l'assemblée nationale et est constaté
que vous êtes parfaitement intégré dans
votre groupe parlementaire est ce votre
première question monsieur le député je
veux répondre avec des chiffres si vous
le voulez bien je suis si vous êtes
attaché au chiffre à date d'hier soir il
avait 5,9 millions de doses de vaccin
antigrippal vendus par les pharmacies de
notre pays
il ya au total 13 millions de doses de
vaccins commandées par les différents
offices pharmacies d'officine de notre
pays
si vous faites 13 - si je voyais qu'il
reste plus de la moitié des doses de
vaccin un certain nombre sont encore
disponibles dans les pharmacies ce n'est
pas 80% de pharmacies qui sont en
pénurie
ces 10 9% le chiffre qui leur revient du
conseil de l'ordre des pharmaciens
hier soir et qui sont des chiffres que
je met à votre disposition
monsieur cormier c'est pas le
gouvernement at-elle vous prenez la tête
au pharmacien c'est eux qui rédige qui
réalisent leur propre stock d'une année
sur l'autre
je suis députée respectée les
pharmaciens 1,3 million de doses de
vaccin antigrippal ont été réallouées
aux pharmacies la semaine dernière un
million deux cent mille doses de vaccin
antigrippal seront réallouées aux
pharmacies cette semaine il en ira de
même la semaine prochaine et la semaine
suivante et monsieur le député parce que
nous avons pour le coût anticipé la
situation
nous avons commandé près de 3 millions
de doses de vaccin en plus des commandes
passées par les pharmaciens
ce qui veut dire que total nous avons
près de 16 millions de doses de vaccins
à répartir sur le territoire jusqu'au
mois de décembre il n'y a pas péril en
la demeure il ya du temps avant que la
grippe arrive monsieur le député donc
pas si ils nous ne sommes pas encore à 6
millions de doses utilisées sur les 16
millions qui seront disponibles au total
pour les français et là je ne je
n'inclus pas dans les six millions de
doses les doses de vaccins qui sont déjà
faites et données pour les soignants de
nos hôpitaux et nos ehpad et père témoin
permettez moi de profiter votre question
pour inviter les personnes vulnérables
qui reçoivent un bon de l'assurance
maladie et inciter les médecins et les
soignants les aides à domicile à se
faire vacciner contre la grippe
encore une fois il ya tout le mois de
novembre et une partie du mois de
décembre pour se faire vacciner et les
vaccins sont réallouées aux pharmacies
progressivement semaine après semaine
comme chaque année monsieur le député
merci monsieur mouche la parole est à
madame anne laurence potel merci
monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des affaires étrangères js
aussi mes collègues de tous les bancs
qui se sont rendus avec moi en arménie
la semaine dernière depuis plus d'un
mois
l'azerbaïdjan soutenu militairement par
la turquie et par des djihadistes venus
de syrie envahi le haut karabagh peuple
est quasi-exclusivement d'arméniens
depuis plus d'un mois
les arméniens font face seul sans aide
internationale dans un combat inégal et
barbare à ce jour 90 mille personnes ont
été déplacées et plusieurs milliers de
morts sont à déplorer
les drones kamikazes et les bombes à
sous-munitions pleuvent chaque jour sur
les civils des armes au phosphore brûle
les forêts de shoushi les populations
sont volontairement ciblé une cathédrale
un centre culturel et même une maternité
ont été bombardés des soldats sont
mutilés décapité rien n'est épargné aux
arméniens soutenir témoigner et rendre
compte tel était le sens de notre
présence en arménie la semaine dernière
au delà des rencontres officielles nous
avons été au chevet des familles
déplacées et des victimes soignée à
l'hôpital
ce que nous avons vu monsieur le
ministre ce sont des jeunes à peine
majeur qui reviennent du combat mutilé
sans jambes sans bras et parfois sans
visage aux portes de l'europe les pires
exactions sont commises en toute
impunité et au mépris du droit
international
à l'heure où nous parlons la capitale et
bientôt coupés du monde et à la merci
des azéri emmanuel macron est le seul
dirigeant occidental à avoir nommé
l'agresseur dénoncé l'ingérence de la
turquie et la présence de djihadistes
le drame qui se joue là bas nous
concerne tous ici erdogan qui provoque
la grèce et chypre agite ses loups gris
en france est le même qui massacrent et
les kurdes et bombardé des arméniens
monsieur le ministre que comptez vous
faire pour mobiliser les européens et
mettre un terme à l' impérialisme
d'erdogan
après le haut karabagh jusqu'où ira-t-il
avec les arméniens nous partageons non
seulement une longue amitié des combats
dans la résistance française mais aussi
l'amour de la démocratie et de la
liberté gimd
la parole est à monsieur jean yves le
drian ministry matin quand j'ai vu de
l'europe
madame la députée anne laurence vettel à
propos du haut karabakh je voudrais
d'abord dire ici toute mon indignation
face aux troupes que nous avons
constatée en france liés aux tensions
suscitées par ce conflit
je condamne donc très fermement la
profanation à décines du mémorial du
génocide de 2002 1915 qui est intervenu
ces derniers jours
c'est cette troupe sont inacceptables et
les autorités françaises ont pris des
mesures pour éviter que de tels actes se
reproduisent
en ce qui concerne le conflit lui-même
vous avez souligné la gravité de la
situation
vous avez souligné aussi apprécions
votre témoignage votre solidarité avec
les arméniens
ce conflit est très grave pas sur les
combats qui s'y déroulent sont d'une
très grande intensité avec des
violations répétées du droit
international que nous faisons
constatées dans ce conflit madame la
députée la france tient sa place c'est à
dire qu'elle se considère toujours comme
coprésidents du groupe de minsk avec des
américains et les russes c'est à dire
qu'elle se considère toujours comme
partie prenante de la médiation et ne
voulons pas nous départir de ce rôle
je le dis parce que j'ai eu l'occasion
de m'entretenir à de nombreuses reprises
avec mon collègue 9,5 à néant sur ce
sujet et il ne conteste pas notre place
et notre rôle dans cette médiation
nous devons donc tenir notre place que
nous avons depuis 1994 que nous assumons
avec les russes et les américains qui a
permis déjà d'avoir trois cessez-le-feu
même s'ils ont été rompues assez
rapidement il n'empêche que nous nous
résignons pas et nous voulons continuer
ce rôle de médiation parce que seuls ses
médiations permettra un arrêt véritable
des hostilités permettra surtout une
relance des négociations et permettra
surtout d'avoir lee
identification des de ceux qui pourront
assurer la sécurité de la cessation des
hostilités et nous en faisons partie
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur frédéric reiss
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur ministre de
l'éducation nationale monsieur le
ministre
dans le cadre du débat sur la mission
enseignement scolaire du plf
nous avons tous rendu hommage à sa mère
pattie sauvagement assassinée à la
veille des vacances de la toussaint lors
de la rentrée du 2 novembre la
communauté éducative avait besoin de la
solidarité nationale
aussi avez vous souhaité monsieur le
ministre décaler cette rentrée à 10
heures c'était le 28 octobre
depuis ordres et contre-ordres se sont
succédé avant que le ministère ne
retiennent finalement l'option d'une
minute de silence à 11 heures pour tous
les élèves
pourtant lors d'une visioconférence avec
les syndicats enseignants vous aviez
prévu un créneau de 8 heures à 10 heures
pour que les professeurs puissent
préparer un hommage à leur collègue
tragiquement disparu pourquoi alors un
tel rétropédalage qui a mécontenté mon
nombre de chefs d'établissement et de
directeur d'école et qui a déstabilisé
parents d'élèves et collectivités
territoriales
qu'en est il des ressources adaptées à
chaque niveau de classe mise à
disposition du corps préfectoral
il y a eu la lettre aux instituteurs de
jean jaurès pour le fond mais dans la
forme c'est le système de débrouille qui
a prévalu pour un hommage fortement
recommandé et qui globalement s'est bien
passé une fois de plus on a eu la
désagréable impression du pas de vagues
le premier ministre et vous même être
allé à conflans sainte honorine et c'est
tout à votre honneur d préfet ont pris
tardivement des initiatives pour aller
dans des écoles mais en sont dans mes
collègues parlementaires leur présence
dans un établissement scolaire a été
très contrasté nombre d'entre eux y sont
allés pour une présence muette avec les
sharks tricolore d'autres sont
intervenus à la demande d'enseignants
d'autres encore ont renoncé parce que
l'inspection académique
le souhaitait pas monsieur le ministre
pourquoi n'avons nous pas réaffirmées
réussi à réaffirmer tous ensemble les
principes fondamentaux de la laïcité et
de la liberté d'expression lors de cette
journée de rentrée si particulière
rendre en hommage à un enseignant qui
aimait passionnément son métier si chers
collègues
la parole est à monsieur jean michel
blanquer ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
frédéric reiss
je retiens d'abord dans ce que vous avez
dit le fait qu'à un moment donné vous
avez dit que ça s'est bien passé hier et
c'est le plus important c'est à dire que
nous avons une unanimité nationale pour
rendre hommage à samuel pâtit et de
grâce ne rencontre pas cette unanimité
parce que nous lui devons ça nous devons
ça aux valeurs qui sont derrière cet
hommage
et bien entendu vous avez un peu de mal
à reconnaître le pourquoi de cela mais
ça je vais y venir maintenant
d'abord dès le début j'ai dit que nous
devions co construire cet hommage c'est
pourquoi dès le lendemain j'ai reçu les
de cet assassinat j'ai reçu les
organisations syndicales et ensemble
nous étions tout à fait d'accord sur
cette co construction
même chose pour les associations de
parents d'élèves pendant ces deux
semaines nous avons reçu l'ensemble des
parties prenantes qui le souhaitaient
dans le cadre du conseil des sages de la
laïcité nous avons donc co construit
cela qui consistait d'abord on à la
lecture de la lettre de jean jaurès la
minute de silence et une heure
d'éducation morale et civique
j'ai fait ce que vous demandez que l'on
fasse c'est à dire de la concertation y
compris avec les associations d'élus et
pour toute personne qui veut bien
observer que s'est il passé d'abord le
confinement qui a été décidé le mercredi
les attentats de nice et tu es
l'association des régions de france qui
m'a dit qu'elle n'arrivait pas à
organiser le transport logistique pour
10 heures du matin le lundi c'est donc
en écoutant les uns et les autres et en
ayant un la préoccupation sanitaire
2 la préoccupation de sécurité oui
monsieur parce que justement j'ai écouté
nous avons écouté jusqu'au bout et dans
cette période si difficile pour la
france il faut savoir justement piloter
en tenant compte de tout ce que disent
les uns les autres et parfois jusqu'à la
dernière minute parce que c'est ainsi
dans des circonstances exceptionnelles
nous avons donc réussi à construire
de là à voir la souplesse nécessaire en
fonction des circonstances aujourd'hui
vous nous le reprocher moi au contraire
j'en suis fier puisque c'est ce qui nous
a permis hier de la réussir cette minute
de silence beaucoup mieux d'ailleurs que
ce qui a pu se passer dans le passé dans
des circonstances analogues et donc
gardons cette unanimité est rendu
hommage à tous les professeurs de france
qui hier ont réussi à faire cette minute
de silence et bien entendu dans
l'unanimité de la république en
associant chaque fois que c'était
possible
les élus de la république merci la
parole est à monsieur le président jean
christophe lagarde
merci monsieur le président notre groupe
à son tour veut exprimer sa solidarité
et sa compassion à nos amis et alliés
autrichien et la détermination de
l'ensemble de l'europe doit avoir à
lutter contre les barbares qui veulent
nous faire changer nos modes de vie et
nos valeurs mais monsieur le premier
ministre je voulais parler de la lutte
contre le virus
aujourd'hui pour pouvoir réussir à
combattre ce virus monsieur le premier
ministre vous avez besoin de l'adhésion
des français c'est leur comportement
d'abord et avant tout qui permettra de
l'emporter pour qu'ils adhèrent il faut
qu'ils comprennent ce que vous faites
c'est l'essentiel en réalité de la
difficulté à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui ils ne
comprennent plus et donc n'adhère pas je
veux prendre j'aurais pu en d'autres
temps remprend d'autres l'exemple des
décisions que vous avez pris sur les
commerces au printemps dernier
l'ensemble des commerces ont été fermés
de ce que vous appelez de non nécessaire
ou non essentiels pourquoi parce qu'il
n'y avait pas de masque il n'y avait pas
de gel il n'y avait pas d'habitude il
n'y avait pas de culture
aujourd'hui on ne comprend pas sur quel
fondement la décision de la fermeture
des commerces de proximité a été prise
très franchement y at il une étude
scientifique qui montreraient qu'ils
sont plus contaminant que d'autres est
ce qu'on peut nous expliquer parmi ceux
qui sont ouverts et ceux qui sont fermés
en quoi un marchand de tissus et moins
contaminant puisqu'il est ouvert qu'un
marchand de vêtements qui lui est fermé
par votre décision
en quoi sur les marchés en milieu ouvert
les commerces alimentaires sont là et
les commerces non alimentaires sont ne
sont pas là parce qu'il serait peut-être
plus contaminant en quoi c'est une dans
une auto école
on a la possibilité de passer l'examen
du permis de conduire mais on ne peut
plus avoir de leçon du permis de
conduire où est la cohérence dans ses
décisions et c'est cela qui pêche
aujourd'hui dans la compréhension et
donc dans l'adhésion des français je le
regrette
monsieur le premier ministre
aviez fait votre arrivée de la
concertation et de la volonté de
territorialisation votre marque de
fabrique
on ne la retrouve pas dans les décisions
du confinement je crains et c'est ce que
vous devriez craindre qu in fine et nous
soyons en ce moment inefficace
sanitairement et est destructeur
économiquement il est encore temps de
s'adapter au terrain nous avons un
projet de loi cet après midi qui
permettrait d'écouter notamment ce que
le sénat a proposé permet aux couples
mère préfet d'adapter vos décisions
merci monsieur prison la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le président jean
christophe lagarde
comme vous le savez toutes et tous hier
encore plus de 400 personnes sont
décédées de la maladie covit 19 des
dizaines des dizaines de milliers de nos
concitoyens
tous âges confondus sont malades avec
des conséquences parfois extrêmement
grave et des séquelles extrêmement
lourde de cette maladie oui la france
comme tous les autres heures pays
européens sont confrontés à une deuxième
vague épidémique particulièrement graves
qui s'est accélérée dans les semaines
passées cette situation mesdames et
messieurs les députés vous le savez je
voulais expliqué jeudi dernier a conduit
le gouvernement à prendre des mesures
importantes et difficiles par le biais
donne au confinement adapter le
confinement vous le savez toutes et tous
consiste à faire en sorte que le maximum
de nos concitoyens restent chez eux pour
casser la progression épidémique et
l'arrivée dans les services d'urgence ça
suppose donc ça suppose donc qu'on
limite à l'essentiel
nos déplacements l'essentiel c'est le
travail comme pour la première vague
c'est et nous avons tiré je voulais
expliquer vous me l'aviez tous demandé
de ne pas fermer les écoles et les
établissements d'enseignement
on a fait évidemment c'est de
s'alimenter c'est à dire les commerces
de première nécessité aller au delà
mesdames et messieurs les députés il
faut le dire c'est ne plus faire de
confinement ne plus faire de confinement
mais monsieur le dpe le président
lagarde je veux vous dire qu autant je
comprends parfaitement
autant je comprends parfaitement les
souffrances endurées par les françaises
et les français et notamment les
commerçants qui n'y sont pour rien à
l'endroit desquels nous prenons ces
mesures indispensables
autant je vous le dis je vous le dit
monsieur le président je ne comprends
pas que vous ayez envoyé aux adhérents
de votre formation politique au sommaire
une demande leur suggérant vivement de
prendre des arrêtés pour s'opposer aux
décisions de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
monsieur le président quand les
françaises et les français sont dans la
difficulté
quand la situation exige des mesures
courageuses et nécessaires
quand la république quand la république
est confronté à la plus grave crise
sanitaire qu'elle ait subie depuis des
décennies on n'appelle pas les mères
serviteur de la république a violé les
lois de la république
ça n'est pas possible
ils ne s'y sont pas trompés ils ne s'y
sont pas trompés seuls 71 d'entre eux
ont pris un arrêté 16 l'ont retirée et
55 l'ont maintenue aux chiffres d'hier
sur 36 me lemaire les maires vous avez
raison sont des gens responsables
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
premier ministre
la parole est maintenant monsieur jean
pierre vigier
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la relance
leur confinement national décrété
mercredi dernier à impacter durement les
petites et moyennes entreprises
françaises et j'espère que vous allez
rapidement changé d'avis concernant les
commerces de seconde nécessité cette
crise nécessite des efforts
considérables pour éviter des plans
sociaux et des licenciements en cascade
j'aimerais également attirer de nouveau
votre attention
concernant une entreprise de mon
territoire dont la situation économique
est très difficile actuellement
le 22 janvier dernier je vous avais
alerté concernant l' usine les
céramiques de haute loire où 82 emplois
sont menacés
la qualité du travail des salariés et le
savoir faire made in france de cette
entreprise de carrelage sont reconnus au
delà de nos frontières
cependant l'usiné placée en redressement
judiciaire depuis un an et sa fermeture
définitive sera prononcé d'ici la fin de
l'année
si aucune solution n'est trouvée le
secrétaire d'état chargé du numérique
avait alors déclaré tout faire pour
trouver un repreneur
neuf mois après la situation d'une usine
n'a pas changé avec l'ensemble des élus
et des salariés de l'entreprise
nous sommes fortement mobilisés pour
trouver un repreneur
deux groupes industriels temps venu sur
place pour étudier une proposition de
reprise
cependant la crise sanitaire la forte
concurrence de certains pays voisins
la suppression d'exonérations fiscales
européennes ont dissuadé les potentiels
intéressés monsieur le ministre il y a
urgence
il y a urgence l'état a le devoir de
trouver rapidement un repreneur
permettant de sauver 80 deux emplois
tous les salariés de l'usiné vous
regarde et attendre vautré port si
monsieur débuté la parole et avale un
bolivien grégoire secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'économie sociale solidaire
et responsable
[Applaudissements]
monsieur vigier l'urgence on est en
plein dedans on en a tous conscience
vous en des moines y ait aujourd'hui
mais c'est aussi en même temps la
relance qu'on doit porter enclenché et
ce sera la meilleure réponse à l'urgence
que vous soulignez sur le dossier que
vous soulignez et les salariés dont vous
rappeler qu'ils sont dans une entreprise
qui connaît des difficultés depuis plus
d'un an maintenant jusqu'à les têtes en
redressement judiciaire
ce que je veux vous dire avec force
c'est d'abord et avant tout que plutôt
que de parler le plan de relance on le
fait le comité national de suivi de
relance présidée par le premier ministre
est réunie vendredi dernier la rapidité
l'effectif l'effectivité de ce plan de
relance est aujourd'hui avec les mesures
d'urgence la meilleure façon de répondre
aux entreprises qui connaissent des
difficultés
15 milliards d'euros sont sur la table
pour relocaliser pourrait attirer à
nouveau dans notre pays des industries
recréer des emplois
nous continuerons à soutenir le bâtiment
vous le savez le plan de relance ma
prime rénove et nous en avons entendu
beaucoup sur le fait que nous ne
faisions pas assez au service de la
rénovation thermique depuis des années
nous prenons nos engagements nous mort
des amis dont les bâtiments de l'état à
hauteur de 4 milliards d'euros nous
demandons aux mairies et vous le savez
de rester ouverte pour pouvoir continuer
à délivrer des permis de construire en
un mot ça c'est des mesures concrètes
pour continuer à soutenir une activité
dans le bâtiment de tp de paix m
et deux pays qui connaissent des
difficultés alors oui je vais vous le
dire monsieur vigier à bercy le dossier
que vous mentionnez est un dossier qui
est regardé de près et nous suivons le
dossier pour essayer de trouver une
solution mais de grâce
entendez aussi que l'urgence et la
relance nous les mais non de ferons nous
si nous sortons de mesure de l'urgence
en avoir anticipé la relance alors nous
resterons dans l'urgence on le fait
ensemble et sur ce dossier on va essayer
de trouver une réponse à la hauteur de
votre mobilisation je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre la parole à
monsieur yves blein merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à madame
olivia grégoire secrétaire d'état à
l'économie sociale solidaire et
responsable dans la revue d'une
entreprise à mission de l'économie
sociale edgar morin s'exprimait
récemment ainsi je pense que du
mouvement mutualiste qu'il est l'avenir
car il va dans le sens d'une économie
guidé par l'intérêt commun et non par la
recherche obsessionnelle du profit
l'économie sociale c'est ma cause
disait-il 222 1000 entreprises 2,3
millions de salariés les entreprises de
l'économie sociale et notamment les
associations voient régulièrement
croître leur part de pib et attire
chaque jour un plus grand nombre de
salariés notamment des jeunes pour qui
la recherche de sens dans leur emploi
prime sur le montant de leur
rémunération
vous êtes madame la secrétaire d'état
membre d'un des trop rares gouvernement
de la vème république dans lequel
l'économie sociale et solidaire est doté
d'un secrétariat d'état de plein
exercice
cela vous confère une responsabilité
particulière doublement importante en
ces temps de crise où l'on sait combien
les acteurs de l'ess sont en première
ligne
renforcement des structures financières
des entreprises amélioration de leurs
ressources
innovation au plus près des territoires
pouvez vous nous dire madame
quelle est votre feuille de route pour
permettre aux entreprises de l'est cesse
de croître en volume et de renforcer
leur place au sein de l'économie
française
comment en ces temps de crise lourde où
de nombreuses entreprises de l'économie
sociale et solidaire s'activent dans les
domaines de la santé de la solidarité du
lien social du sport des loisirs du
tourisme de l'éducation
comment entendez vous faire en sorte
qu'elles puissent bénéficier pleinement
du plan de relance et que l'ensemble des
aides massives consacré aux activités
économiques et l emploi leur soient au
même titre que toute entreprise
facilement accessibles la parole est à
van hamme olivia grégoire secrétaire
d'état chargée de l'économie sociale
solidaire et responsable
monsieur blain merci de cette question
je vais vous paraphraser l'économie
sociale et solidaire c'est aussi votre
cause est votre cause depuis un certain
nombre d'années
c'est un sujet que vous connaissez bien
et vous relevé un paradoxe qui est assez
fort cette économie sociale et solidaire
elle est souvent en première ligne et
vous l'avez dit pour répondre à la crise
à l'urgence notamment sociales elle est
aussi une des premières à être fragilisé
par cette même crise où il savait les
structures de l'économie sociale et
solidaire
bien souvent elles s'occupent plus des
autres que d'elle-même bien souvent
elles n'ont pas nécessairement les
équipes ou l'ingénierie suffisante pour
pouvoir aller chercher des aides elles
manquent parfois de ressources la
première des urgences
la première de mes d'urgence au service
de l'économie sociale et solidaire c'est
de faire en sorte qu'elle sache et je le
dis avec force que l'ensemble des
mesures économiques qui sont valables
pour les entreprises pour les tpe pour
les pme le sont aussi pour l'intégralité
des acteurs de l'économie sociale et
solidaire et lyon pleinement droit et
aujourd'hui nous avons affaire à un
problème de non recours
nous devons tous ensemble leur faire
savoir les parlementaires le
gouvernement l'ensemble de
l'administration qu'elles sont éligibles
à l'ensemble de ces aides
je fais tout ton le faire savoir nous
avons mis en place un guide jeu réactive
la cellule de crise avec les têtes de
réseau et nous avons fait en sorte que
bercy par son numéro vert répondre
précisément aux acteurs de le ss vous
l'avez dit l'économie sociale est solide
c'est une économie à part entière c'est
aussi une économie à part qui parfois
souffre de la faiblesse de ses fonds
propres
c'est pourquoi nous travaillons avec les
banques pour leur demander la
bienveillance dans les mois qui viennent
nous travaillons sur ce sujet pour
permettre que les acteurs de le ss
puisse passer cette deuxième vague
depuis trois mois vous l'avez dit
monsieur blanc l'économie sociale et
solidaire est de retour à bercy
elle y est pour y rester elle y est pour
tout ce qu'elle est ellle est aussi pour
tout ce qu'elle fait c'est une économie
des conséquences au coeur de la crise je
veux le dire avec force elle doit avoir
accès à l'ensemble des dispositifs
merci les modèles économes je vous
remercie la parole merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse au
premier ministre
je veux vous interroger sur votre
méthode ce matin même le porte-parole du
gouvernement déclare que le couvre-feu
sera instauré à paris à partir de 21h il
est aussitôt démenti vos mesures manque
d'anticipation et de concertation car
ces mesures sont annoncés parfois
seulement quelques jours voire quelques
heures avant leur mise en place sans
concertation ni avec la représentation
nationale ni avec les syndicats
représentant des professions impactée ni
même avec les élus locaux
en fait monsieur le premier ministre si
vos décisions qu'ont contestés par les
français ce n'est pas parce qu'il
conteste la lutte contre la pandémie
mais parce qu'ils ne comprennent plus
les mesures prises qu'il juge brutal et
injuste
comment expliquer que les supermarchés
les écoles les transports puisse rester
ouvert avec un protocole certes mais que
le petit commerce lui avec le même
protocole ne peut pas être ouvert en
fait nous sommes dans la verticalité la
plus absolue
le parlement est dessaisi de ses
prérogatives les élus locaux et les
citoyens sont sommés de se soumettre à
ces décisions qui viennent d'en haut
pourquoi ne pas avoir renforcé les
mesures de protection pour le petit
commerce avec la jauge des quatre mètres
carrés sans les fermer
pourquoi ne pas avoir pris appui sur les
mers comme pour les marchés pour
permettre des protocoles adaptés
permettant l'ouverture des petits
commerces vous avez dit monsieur le
premier ministre qu'ils étaient
responsables
c'est vrai vous parlez de manière
générale de différenciation vous ne la
mettez pas en oeuvre
alors que l'on sait que les taux de
contaminations et de mortalité sont
différents en fonction des territoires
ma question est simple allez vous
changer de méthode pour susciter
l'adhésion de tous les français à
paroles comme chez olivier veyrat
ministre des solidarités de la santé
monsieur le député paul molac je ne vous
rappellerait pas que semaine après
semaine depuis le mois d'août
à mesure que nous avertissons sur les
signes de reprise épidémique les mesures
ont été mises en place différencier
territorialisée en fonction de la
situation épidémique propres à chaque
territoire en tentant par tous les
moyens d'expliquer voire de faire
comprendre aux acteurs locaux certains
avec succès parfois avec moins de succès
pourquoi est ce que nous prenions des
mesures pour freiner la circulation du
virus avec la concertation des préfets
des maires des présidents de
départements je pourrais vous faire la
liste mais ça prendrait beaucoup de
temps
innombrables des élus auxquels nous
avons les uns et des autres parler
semaine après semaine
ce député prg ministre a très bien
expliqué tout à l'heure pourquoi les
commerces
nous voulons limiter les contacts
physiques nous laissons aux français la
possibilité de sortir pour envoyer
emmener les enfants à l'école pour
s'éduquer la possibilité de travailler
mais en privilégiant le télétravail de
se déplacer pour les courses qui sont
indispensables et le reste du temps de
rester chez eux
monsieur député je ne sais pas comment
expliquer un français en tout cas moi je
ne suis pas sûr de pouvoir expliquer à
un ami pourquoi il aurait encore le
droit d'aller acheter un jeans mais
qu'il n'aurait pas le droit de prendre
l'apéritif chez un ami monsieur député
la réponse elle est là dans la
limitation des contacts sociaux
c'est exactement ce qui est mis en place
dans la plupart des pays qui nous
entourent
vous savez il ya 45 % des français dans
une étude qui est sorti ce week-end qui
considère que nous n'en faisons pas
assez en termes de mesures pour freiner
le virus alors qu'il ya 15% des français
qui considèrent qu'on en fait trop
je trouve monsieur le député concours et
chacun est libre de cette séance on a
beaucoup parlé des 15 % de français qui
considèrent qu'on en fait trop
oubliant peut-être un peu de représenter
les 85 % de français qui ont peur du
virus qui sont prêts à faire des efforts
et qu'ils attendent de la représentation
nationale qui les comprennent
débutée monsieur le ministre je vous
assure que dans ma circonscription j'ai
été saisi pendant tout le week-end et ça
fait sale et c'est une vraie traînée de
poudre je peux vous dire que vos mesures
ne sont pas comprises par les français
et donc il est jeune et je dirais que
vous ne vous appuyer pas à l'avant ce en
concertation sur la représentation
nationale et sur les élus locaux qui
sont prêts à vous aider
et c'est bien ça que je vous reproche
merci monsieur le député monsieur le
ministre je vous renvoie la balle
monsieur le député nous avons besoin la
représentation nationale nous avons
besoin des ambassadeurs que vous êtes
dans votre territoire vous qui êtes au
contact de la population des commerçants
des élus pour expliquer que si nous
prenons des décisions
à l'instar de l'ensemble de nos voisins
pour protéger les populations c'est
peut-être que ces décisions sont
justifiées par la situation sanitaire
si vous partez du principe que nous
faisons n'importe quoi on n'arrivera
jamais à s'entendre et à se comprendre
si vous partez du principe que en france
comme ailleurs à l'étranger
les décisions sont des décisions de bon
sens qui vise à protéger les populations
alors messieurs les buts et non
seulement nous nous arriverons à nous
entendre
mais peut-être que les français aussi
arriveront à vous entendre merci
monsieur lui laisser la parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame amélie de montchalin
la ministre de la transformation et de
la fonction publique
imad e-bay athènes
mohamed le guen abel chez nous ahmed
mera b franck brun solaro clarissa
jean-philippe damien airness brice le
mais ce camp aurélia tri firo samuel
pâtit il était militaire policier
fonctionnaire d'état ou territoriaux ou
professeurs ils étaient les garants de
nos valeurs républicaines et pour nous
pour la france ils sont morts
si hier les personnes dépositaires de
l'autorité publique ou chargée d'une
mission de service public faisait
l'objet d'agressions et d'incivilités
elles sont aujourd'hui les cibles de
l'islamisme radical et de sa barbarie et
face à cela les fonctionnaires se sent
bien seul ce sentiment d'abandon est
bien trop souvent répondu dont
rond de nos agents publics bien trop
souvent ils font l'objet de menaces
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux voire
d'agressions ou d'attac dans l'exercice
de leur fonction est bien trop souvent
ils ne sont pas soutenus par leur
hiérarchie est bien trop souvent ils
cèdent et s'autocensurent là et le prix
pour ne pas mettre sa vie et celle de
ses proches en danger pour autant madame
la ministre vous l'avez reconnue vous
même le recours à la protection
fonctionnelle dans les situations les
plus difficiles et trop rare et trop
lent comment affirmer à nos agents
publics qu'ils seront écoutés considérer
soutenu et protégé
quelle mise en oeuvre pour que la
protection fonctionnelle de nos agents
publics retrouve tout son efficience
que compte faire le gouvernement afin
que ces agents publics en premier lieu
desquels les professeurs ne renonce
jamais à transmettre les valeurs de la
république
merci la parole est à madame amélie de
montchalin ministre de la transformation
de la fonction publique
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés chère madame la
députée kuryk renforcer la protection de
ceux et celles qui chaque jour font
vivre notre république et ses valeurs
c'était plus qu'une urgence après ce
terrible et lâche assassinat de sa mère
pattie parce que nos agents publics
parce que nos services publics parce que
notre république
c'est notre plus solide rempart contre
l'idéologie islamiste
parce qu'aussi nos agents se sont ces
héros du quotidien qui font vivre la
république alors le premier ministre et
le président m'ont dit quand un agent
est attaqué c'est la république qui est
attaqué alors en leur nom en tant que
ministre la transformation de la
fonction publique mon devoir c'est de
donner tous les moyens à tous de mieux
les protéger
vous l'avez dit depuis 1983 la loi pose
les principes d'une protection
fonctionnelle des agents mais nous
voyons qu'elle n'est aujourd'hui pas
toujours efficace qu'elle n'est pas
toujours activé et surtout qu'elle ne
prend pas toujours en compte
elle ne prend même pas en compte les
menaces sur les réseaux sociaux et sur
internet
ce que nous allons faire grâce à une
circulaire à mon initiative signée hier
soir par eric dupond moretti le garde
des sceaux par le ministre de
l'intérieur jarlard maintenant et par
madame chapeau c'est que immédiatement
nous avons posé trois principes très
clairs et très fort quand il ya une
menace en ligne d'abord la hiérarchie
est tenu de le signaler par une
procédure arty 40 au procureur à la
république ensuite ce signalement doit
être fait également à la plateforme
pharos et enfin nous devons à chaque
fois que c'est nécessaire
faire le lien avec les forces de l'ordre
pour que les domiciles des agents soient
protégés cette protection et doit être
accordée sans délai elle doit être
accordée à titre conservatoire dès lors
que la menace est gris grave ou
imminente
je les dis nous devons absolument mettre
fin à ce pas de vagues
aucun agent ne peut encore d'un autre
pays aujourd'hui se sentir seul
quand il fait son métier qu'il défend
nos valeurs et que la menace elle est
diffusée et protéiforme nous sommes donc
aux côtés des agents nous les
protégerons est plus que jamais nous
lors de vos soutiens parce qu'ils
défendent sans faille et chaque jour nos
principes et notre république
merci madame la milice la séance des
questions au gouvernement est terminée